if you're stuck and you want to become
unstuck and make progress Go Master a
new skill set to the point where you can
write a book on it the point where you
can provide that service or skill set to
other people as a service provider at
that point you can open so many doors
but as long as you keep reading about
that and not doing it you're going to
stay where you're at second piece of
advice would be to really master your
emotions when it comes to money once you
can do that the world your oyster you
can do anything because you can apply
that skill set to absolutely anything in
any industry that inspires you and
that's really the key to to success
these days and the moment you take your
eye off the product and the Nu's
customer and how much they're enjoying
it get out of the business cuz it's
going to kick you out so if you're going
to start a business and you're younger
I'm willing to wait 10 20 years cuz I
fully expect young people think they're
Invincible I believe that the fast lane
to Financial Freedom is to build a
business and invest the profits and if I
were to say the
faster Lane would be to build a business
and sell it automatically placing that
into some sort of a long-term investment
so for me that's just I have E Trade
deduct a certain amount from my checking
account every month and I go and I put
that in the dividend pays money revealed
is an exclusive video series where
self-made millionaires share their
secrets on how they got rich in this
episode you'll learn how to make
investing easy the key skills for
success in any industry and why you need
to serve first if you want to get rich
these are the lessons that they don't
teach you in school about making money
and we've partnered with the series
Creator Jeff Hayes to bring it to you on
my YouTube channel
enjoy I'm a great admirer of Mike
Dillard I've read his newsletters for a
long time and he's someone who is
greatly admired in the entrepreneurial
world we were excited to go to Austin to
sit down with him and gain insight and
wisdom from him and he's just got a
style and a delivery in a way of
communication that is ex extremely
powerful and compelling but also it's
just no hype what you see is what you
get there's great Insight here and it's
something that I'm very excited to bring
to you enjoy my interview with Mike
Dillard Mike you have such a great
reputation I really been looking forward
to this conversation so thanks for
making the time yeah absolutely looking
forward to it so let's talk about uh
maybe just your entrepreneurial journey
and background how didd you get started
in being an entrepreneur oh gosh that
goes back to my days in high school MH
and waiting tables at the original
Macaroni Grill in bar Texas yeah which
was same building as the original Rudy's
barbecue and I used to mountain bike
race competitively and I needed money to
fund that so i' I'd bust tables uh at
night during
school and I really earned an
appreciation for the lack of Freedom
that comes with having a job and the
fact that I'd miss out on a lot of good
times with with friends on the weekends
and I'd come home at you know 11:12 1:00
in the morning exhausted smelling like
food and would head back home to my
parents house turn on television at that
late at night there's really only one
thing on at 1:00 a.m. back in those days
which was infomercials so watching Tony
Robbins and Carlton sheets and all of
those guys and that really just exposed
me to the fact that there was other
options available and options without
limitations which really appealed to me
so it was a natural fit but that was the
inspiration and started playing with
uh you know starting little businesses
way back in high school and college and
that's where I got my start what' you
study in college uh first semester was
biology I was going to be a dentist
because at the time my uncle was the
most successful wealthiest person in our
family tree and I was like okay if I
have no other other interest that seems
like the smartest thing to do uh
immediately found out what beer was when
I showed up to the dorm because I never
drank in high school since I was cycling
and my first semester I got a
13 um so immediately changed changed
plans and I went to summer school on
probation switched over to
marketing and did well there but uh I
honestly never went to class I went to
Barnes & Noble and I'd sit in the
business section reading books on the
floor skipped all of my classes and then
I would go pay 50 60 bucks to go to the
cram sessions you know 3 days before you
get all the old tests right and that's
what I did for 5 years until I passed
with a
2.0 and uh my theory on that was that I
went to class as much as I need to and
automated more yeah uh I already knew I
wanted to to be an entrepreneur so the
degree for me was kind of pointless so
what did you do when you got out so what
was your first business venture first
business venture was in the network
marketing industry and this is web 1.0
days this is early 2000s
2201 and uh at the time this is pre-
social media no YouTube Facebook pre
Myspace uh but I had a mentor that had
been working with me over the phone for
about a year named Stu out in California
and I said Stu I'm packing up my truck
after I graduate a week later and I'm
coming to learn from you until I figure
this out how did you find Stu I mean how
did he come into your life uh probably
through the network marketing business I
was in at the time
and uh so that's what I did I packed up
my old Chevy truck with everything I
owned from my dorm said goodbye to the
folks drove to California got to San
Diego where he was and realized I could
not afford anywhere in San Diego so I
kept going to Tula found a $300 a month
apartment uh I had my bed my desk and a
chair and that was it and the living
room was full of boxes from my my
memorabilia and college
stuff and that was September 10th 2001 M
so the next morning wow I got a phone
call from mom freaking out and that was
uh that was a big change in plans
because at the time if you're
selling opportunity if you're selling
hope if you're selling a brighter better
future and all of a sudden the world
changes overnight that's not really
something that people are in the mood to
to talk about at the moment and so our
our plans at at that time really took a
dive got a job at Best Buy selling
computers there in Tula for probably 3 4
months couldn't pay the bills at seven
bucks hour eight bucks an hour whatever
I was making and eventually headed back
home to to Texas and it was a tough
lesson learned but but interesting
timing and yeah so that was the first uh
that was the first Venture so uh maybe
just as a now with the reflective wisdom
after being through this the the role of
a mentor in the development of being an
entrepreneur and the and the role of
timing where things happen because
you're also on the heels of the dot
bubble burst right so that that kind of
process in 911 happened so you know how
how timing might influence your
plans timing is interesting because it
can it can throw a wrench in a certain
set of plans and it can create
opportunities in different ways if you
have the skill sets to capitalize on
that and at the time I didn't have any
skills I was still trying to figure it
out so I don't think at the end of the
day it would have made a difference
either way uh because I just didn't know
what I was doing but it was I think the
determination was the biggest piece of
the puzzle and I really made up my mind
at that point that I was going to become
an entrepreneur I was basically going to
die trying uh you know IID planned when
I couldn't make rent or pay my cell
phone bill one month I was like okay I
can get a gym membership I can take a
shower there maybe I can find an air
conditioned rental unit and I'll sleep
there and then I'll figure it out and
that's where my thinking was going there
wasn't any plan b or you know ID of
quitting so so what's interesting is
that um a lot of people might have
reacted in that circumstance by saying
uh well I guess I'm not meant to do this
you know the way things unfolded which
you the meant to be things I always find
that to be a confusing premise but uh
but in in your case it was like there
was you weren't dissuaded you know by
the circumstances you were still going
to work to go through them what do you
think the compulsion was I mean because
this is really the heart of an
entrepreneur isn't it the idea of having
a job and giving up on everything I
wanted to do in life was infinitely more
painful than living in a storage unit
yeah yeah that was it that was it just
that simple yeah so then what unfolded
from there gosh moved back to San
Antonio got a job uh briefly in Dallas
recruiting surgeons this the biggest
piece of advice I ever got was a mentor
in that industry at the time and I'd
gone on for 5 years and failed didn't
make a dime for five years in a row and
it got to a point where I was like okay
something's got to change here and he
finally gave me a really good piece of
honest advice and he said Mike the
reason you're not hitting your financial
goals in this industry is because you're
not capable of getting the result that
you want you're not that person right
now and you've been chasing these
opportunities if you will and I put all
the responsibility for Success on
something outside of myself either it
was the business or the product or the
marketing materials but I thought
success was going to come as a result of
those things and he had finally dawned
on me when he said that he said if you
want to go make let's say $50,000 a
month cuz that was my big lifelong dream
at the time M he's like you have to
become a person who's capable of
achieving that and he's like you're not
right now you're not you don't have any
Mastery of any skill sets
whatsoever and I was like ah okay and it
was a big light bul moment for me so
from that point forward I dove in head
first into every book I could find on
sales marketing lead generation and
copywriting specifically I was very shy
at the time I hated talking to people in
person person selling it was just the
scariest thing in the world for me to do
even over the even over the
phone so I learned how to sell via
writing VI copywriting and it took me
about a year year and a half of just
going into every course I could and I'd
sit down at night uh and print out
successful you know sales presentations
and letters from some of the greats like
Dan Kennedy or David ogbe and and guys
like that and I would just rewrite them
out by hand and I did that every night
for a year about a year and I learned
that skill set and all of a sudden I was
like man I can really sell something
here and then I taught myself how to use
Google AdWords and now how do I get
eyeballs in front of what I've written
and that really changed everything uh I
applied that skill to my network
marketing business at the time started
recruiting people for the first time
ever built a team pretty quickly about 3
or 400 people and realized I absolutely
hated
it um this was like five six years of
pursuing this dream and I finally have
it and I figured it out and it was
miserable uh it just wasn't a part of my
personality being a really introverted
person right so that was another big
chapter where um decision point do I
give up on this dream of building a
business in that industry for six seven
years now or or do I stick with it and
the solution or the answer that I came
up with was what if I could build this
business in a way that I really enjoyed
and for me the answer was that to that
was just how do I get people to call
call me instead how do I stop chasing
people and how do I get them to to come
after
me and there was just a little twist you
know at the time to doing that which is
providing value if you put out value
into the world surprise surprise you
help other people they want to work with
you and and essentially there's this
whole attraction marketing philosophy
that I happened to introduce to that
industry at the time so this was 2004
2005 and no one in that world had ever
heard of that they had never heard of
online lead generation they never heard
of building a business online they never
heard of Attraction
marketing and I ended up writing this
little 50-page training manual for my
team at the time that kind of talked
about those philosophies and strategies
and all of a sudden I had phone calls
from people all over the world saying
hey can I sell this manual to my team
can you make one for our team so I ended
up selling it for 40 bucks a copy online
I'd go down to Kinkos I'd have 300
printed at a time little cheap spiral B
binding for two three bucks a
piece put up a a sales letter for it put
it on Google and within I think 3 or 4
months I was selling around $50,000 a
month worth of that book and that was an
even bigger shift because now I really
felt like I was pursuing my talent and
what I was good at which was teaching
and I'd really discovered that and so
that really turned into an education
company where we took the skills which
were brand new of online marketing and
taught it to that industry and that
turned into an eight fig business so wow
so uh it's interesting because it seems
like and maybe this is an important
foundation for an entrepreneur is they
have to know themselves uh really well
to be able to kind of keep moving
forward where you said gez I got what I
wanted and I ended up hating it so you
said you had to learn things about
yourself well in the beginning you're
just like tell me what to do MH you know
put me on coach and I'll do whatever you
say and that's what I did you know for
those five years and I was like okay
this isn't working and I'm miserable
what's got to change and you know
interesting interestingly enough that
industry is built for people who love
networking they are extroverts they love
meeting people talking to people and you
stick someone like me in there who
shrinks in that environment and then
expect to see success yeah it's uphill
battle for sure so yeah so if if uh some
were to ask you so what do you do for a
living how would you describe
it you know previously I've I've I've
really just considered myself uh an
educator in the fact that I tend to
build companies based on my own personal
challenges so whatever my biggest
challenge in is in life I'll go work on
the solution and figuring that out for
many years until I do and then I'll
teach other people who have that exact
same problem what I learned M and that's
really been the heart of what I've done
for the last 12 years and two different
companies now we're you know with that
I've been challenging myself in in new
ways to you know put myself as an
entrepreneur in general outside of that
realm which has been an interesting
learning experience as well so yeah well
recently you've been uh writing a lot of
uh great copy because I've been reading
it around uh
cryptocurrency what what got you
attracted to
that you know I don't remember exactly
what caught my eye but I found Bitcoin
in
2012 I bought my first Bitcoin in 2013
on Mount gox 2012 was a little too
sketchy you get on these fors or blogs
and and it would be send this Anonymous
person your credit card info and money
and they'll send you this Bitcoin back
and at that time you know it was
probably pennies fractions of a penny so
unfortunately I unfortunately my radar
went off a little too late uh but or a
little too soon I should say but but
I I set up an account on Mount gox and
bought 500 Bitcoin and and just was like
hey if nothing happens great Vegas money
if something does happen great and
unfortunately a year later uh MX got
hacked and I lost all my Bitcoin oh my
goodness oh wow that's real unfortunate
yes yeah yeah so I paid attention to the
industry a little bit I think I bought
back in when Bitcoin was about $700 in
2015 2016 I don't remember the exact
date and started to notice what was
going on with ethereum as well when it
was about $56 and and at that point I
really started to dive into that
industry in a pretty big way and I saw I
saw what was going to come from that the
next 10 15 years pretty quickly so was
there something about it sort of uh you
either spiritually or philosophically
you said wow the idea of a
non-government controlled currency
intrigues me is that one of the things
that brought you there yeah you know for
sure um I was buying gold in
26 2006 2007 Bine silver you know when
it was
$7 uh saw the writing on the wall with
the financial collapse and and for
anyone who was studying economics and
finance at that time we should have seen
the entire thing collapse right and it
took trillions of dollars in money
printing to you know prop it up and keep
it alive so I've always had a a bit of
distrust around people in power who have
control over unlimited bank account and
credit card and you know we're the ones
who end up paying the bill so yeah yeah
so now uh what is your now that you've
seen all the things unfold and it things
continue to unfold it's a fascinating
world the whole cryptocurrency and
blockchain world uh what do you see
moving forward what do you think's going
to happen you know it's really
interesting there's two there's two
sides of it there's the the truly
decentralized uh currencies like Bitcoin
that basically cannot be controlled m
and the real evangelist the maximalist
if you will of that world think that
that's going to take over the world and
become the deao Global Currency maybe it
will maybe it won't that'll require Mass
adoption so what I've been most
interested in following is how our
government specifically the US going to
react right because you're not going to
see Mass adoption if they come out like
China did and say crypto and bitcoin's
illegal right you'll get Pirates and
Rebels who will use it but if you can't
buy Starbucks with it it's not going to
reach that point so following what the
sec's done and the policies that they've
put out over the last year
specifically they're looking to blend
the two and I don't know exactly how
that's going to work out um but the
genie out of the bottle at this point
what really excites me the
most I guess is the the tokenization of
Securities and and real physical assets
I think that's where the real Revolution
is going to take place here in the
coming years when anyone can take their
business bus s house and tokenize the
value and pull out the
equity you know that's going to be
gamechanging walk through what that mean
so you have a house you got equity in it
what would it mean to tokenize it well
at this point if you want to essentially
raise money you for your business let's
say your your biggest option outside of
taking you know private funding is to
take it public right which is basically
impossible these days unless you're a
billion dollar company right so uh that
door has been closed and now essentially
you're going to be able to take any real
asset you have again your business your
gas station your home your bed and
breakfast whatever it may be divide it
up uh into shares assign those to a
token and then share those on an
exchange or let people buy them invest
in them you can take quarterly profits
and automatically distribute those based
on a per token basis to everybody's
wallet who owns it and it can be as fast
and as simple as that so basically the
token becomes your your stock or your
Equity that you're selling into a public
Marketplace that people can invest in
and now you're you're starting to cite
the whole well how's the SEC going to
look at this cuz they kind of there's
regulation around Securities and who can
offer them and how they're offered Etc
so what's the uh the current status of
of that as far as the SEC is concerned
you know I think it's going to be
treated very the same way as stock
anybody can jump on any trade and buy
stock right now the difference is what
can what assets can you turn into stock
basically and how easily can you do that
and and that's really where where the
big change is going to take place so uh
lots to figure out yet but uh I think
that's going to be that's going to be
gamechanging is there an emerging
business of uh people that would say hey
I'm going to do the pick and shovels of
this thing uh where I'm going to create
the platforms for people to tokenize
because you know the chance person who
says Hey I want to raise some funds and
I want to use this vehicle I mean you
know what how do they how do they do it
so obviously you know the the trading
platforms need to be built is is there a
movement underfoot to do that one of
your the guests of this of this movie
Patrick Burn yeah and t0 yeah absolutely
so I've been following TZ since since
he's announced that and obviously
Patrick and I have a lot in common
philosophy wise when it comes to money
so I'm very excited about what they're
doing and uh what role do you want to
play moving forward in all this you know
the role I've taken right now is to help
introduce people to what
cryptocurrencies about and how to
participate safely at this point it's
still the wild west I still see friends
on Facebook oh my God my phone was
hacked and my wallet was hacked and my
bitcoin's gone wow and these are smart
people these are entrepreneurs this is
not Mom and Dad 70 years old trying to
figure this out and that's just a huge
issue right now so the role I've taken
is here's what cryptocurrency is here's
what crypto assets are here's how they
work from a Layman's perspective and
most importantly here's how you store
them safely and and train act safely you
know
even you you look at the infrastructure
we're dealing with right now and and
outside of coinbase you're dealing with
my ether wallet and and all of these
other tools
that unless you're an engineer software
engineer a programmer you you're going
to have a tough time trying to figure
out just how to use it and so right now
I'm trying to serve as the guide around
that stuff and um and get people
involved while the timing's right so
it's still education in Ence right just
point your educational uh prowess toward
this as compared to some of the other
things that you've done before yeah you
know it's interesting as you mentioned
that is that um yeah I I got very
excited about uh Bitcoin and crypto when
it first came out because of my own
philosophy towards money and uh you just
I just wanted to morally support it and
and hoped it had a future uh but what
you say and this is why it's a real need
I mean I come from you know my last
business was a technology business you
so I'm not I'm not Tech adverse I'm
really Tech you know oriented and when I
looked at what it meant to try to
purchase Bitcoin this is back probably
when it was trading around $600 or so I
think we and I I said I'm going to go
get some of this you know just just to
morally support it and also I think it's
a cool thing and I think it might
actually do something we'll see but by
the time I really started to look at
what does it take to purchase it you
know what does it take to have a wallet
what are the risks how do you have the
securitize for me it seemed so complex
and difficult I said I can't imagine
adoption at this point because you know
I'm somebody who's kind of tech oriented
and you know the average Joe is just not
going to be able to weather this as long
as you're expecting people to scan QR
codes and copy and paste public Keys
yeah you're not going to see it right
and you know one of the one of the
projects that I follow is all about
putting the the visual layer if you will
on top of the blockchain so everything
is in the form of you know a graphical
asset basically and you don't see the
code anymore if you want to send someone
an asset you just swipe it or text them
you know this little digital icon and
that's it and it's a digital asset at
that point it can't be copied duplicated
and you own it um we're going to see an
entirely new world of assets represented
with these might be a can of coke at uh
you know the store downstairs I I have
one on my phone represents a real can of
Coke I can go up to the machine I can
you know make that transfer and out
comes a real can of Coke and the digital
version gone it's going to be really a
really neat future here but we're just
now going through the ideation phase of
what it could be so and I and I think
that's going to be the Tipping Point
when it gets kind of consumer friendly
in that respect of the adoption I think
will be exponential uh at that point
yeah once you once you're using
blockchain without knowing that you're
using blockchain is when is when frankly
the opportunity is over yeah um so right
now the more complicated it is for
people which is what I tell them the
fact that this is difficult and hard
means that there's an opportunity here
so
well uh were you surprised um like when
I first was seeing this that the
government stayed passive because as you
said the genie is out of the bottle now
I thought the government would try to
clamp down on this so quickly because
you know government control of currency
is a major Foundation of of why the
government thinks it's it exists right
um and then suddenly it it was out and
they were doing nothing was that
surprising to
you yes and no and I've had a lot of
conversations with some really smart
friends about this CU I still don't
understand why either and you know so
the global crypto market cap the
entire entire asset ecosystem around the
world is less than $300 billion today
that's around the market cap of
Walmart uh so I don't think they're
paying attention to it or at least they
weren't initially because it was just
small and a in a fringe
application but I
also don't think that they could get
anything accomplished quick enough
anyway does anything move fast in
Washington takes years right and this is
moving faster than any other
Technologies developed uh the adoption
is moving faster than anything else and
so I don't even if they wanted to I
don't think that they would practically
be able to make it happen and so there
have been a lot of smart entrepreneurs
like Patrick who've been out essentially
lobbying and educating Washington and
saying look this is here it's not going
away so now we have two options do we
become this C Cent Hub of development
and Innovation as we were for
essentially the first internet
applications or do we let that go
somewhere else to Singapore South Korea
or you know somewhere else and I think
they're smart enough to know we want the
brain power and we want the assets here
in the US so I think that's the way that
it's going to go certainly a compelling
argument uh you know saying hey this is
out there and now who's going to take
the lead right yeah now what about the
wider application of blockchain you know
beyond you know a currency but you know
what else it can do in the world what
are you
seeing well beyond a
currency and around the tokenization of
Securities it really is just it just
comes down to people and there's going
to be two different types of
applications there's a truly
decentralized application which takes
people out of the process and it's you
know it's funny I have I have a a very
smart entrepreneur friend here in town
who is not a fan of Bitcoin or
blockchain and and he's like I I just I
know it's going to get hacked I know
people someone's going to come in and
and corrupt it MH and it just told me
that it doesn't really get it because
you buy Bitcoin and use crypto because
you don't trust people and you don't
want people involved in the process
right
so you know I think the big the big
piece around this is is Bitcoin is
creating a trust-based economy it's
taking inefficiencies that are created
in any Market by fraud theft you know
obfuscation and deceit and it's going to
get rid of that and that's I think the
big transformational piece of this uh
you look at from myself as a business
owner and using merchant services and
I'm paying 3 4% you know Merchant fees
uh to AMX and visa and MasterCard and
stripe and everybody else and now I can
take payments via crypto for a fraction
of a penny right yeah you know I'm in so
it's really going to be interesting to
see how those companies start to adopt
as well I know I know many of them Visa
specifically has been filing dozens and
dozens of patents around
cryptocurrency and while at the same
time you know talking it down and and
all of that stuff as well so well well
smart people would they do exactly that
they're going to hedge their bets on the
threat right you know saying hey this is
you nonsense and inappropriate but at
the same time they're they they've got
patents I know a lot of company well you
mentioned Walmart I think Walmart's got
a bunch of patents on crypto if I'm not
mistaken so uh you know it's been
interesting to see how people are
scrambling right now to to try to
position themselves for this uh because
it it is it's on a tear that I think you
know it's almost dizzying as far as how
fast things are unfolding yeah you know
luckily right now this is the Calm
before the storm post bubble in 2017
and uh it's it's a huge opportunity
we're still really really really early
in this uh I think we're going to it's
going to take another 5 to 10 years
before you know 80% of the population's
using it like their Visa card so yeah
we're super early still and and you know
so do you think we're you know in
another bubble now and if there was a
economic bubble that was going to burst
what do you think is going to happen to
cryptocurrency when that you know with
that I think the US Stock Market is
entering a bubble for sure when you're
hitting all new highs every month every
week you're in a bubble yeah and so it's
going to be really interesting to see
how crypto reacts when that pops is that
money going to go in Bitcoin or is it
just going to into cash and stay there
and I don't know the answer to that um
you know I view Bitcoin as digital gold
as a lot of people do right
now and so yeah it's going to be very
interesting and I don't have the answer
but I know I know what I'm betting
on and uh with with that um do you think
because you you mentioned Bitcoin do
what about all I mean there's I guess
over thousand or thousands of uh
cryptocurrencies now
uh do you think the Market's over
flooded with them and it's going to be a
wash out or what's going to happen there
95% of them be gone in a couple of years
and you know that's great I think all of
the ideas and Innovation are necessary
it it's going to find its its value in
an Open Marketplace and the winners will
stick but 95% of them will end up just
like the dotcom days the question is now
which do you invest in yeah and
unfortunately just like in the Doom days
you don't know so at least My Philosophy
has been over the last couple of years
is to put a little bit a little bit of
money in in all of them uh at least the
the top 50 to 100 that uh that are out
there
and the big piece for me is is this
going to replace an
existing Market or business or function
that exists right now that has a really
large user base is this going to allow
that to be done faster easier and and
more
efficiently there's a lot of
applications out are brand new ideas
let's tokenize the dental records
industry maybe yeah maybe put a couple
hundred bucks in it maybe ,000 do in it
Vegas money yeah uh but for the most
part I think all of those are going to
go away at the end of the day a
blockchain is a database uh the real
value of a blockchain is a distributed
one but most of them are not they're
centralized right and at that point you
just need a database use Google use
Microsoft
uh you know SQL whatever you want you
don't need a blockchain for it that's
distributed and and being used around
the world for that functionality well
what's interesting um is that typically
if you're like looking to uh to invest
in equities or even to speculate into
markets there's some fundamentals you
know well like if you're going to do you
know pre-bubble you'd say okay well who
are the who's the team right that you
know that's doing this you know oh Jeff
Bezos he's he's he's running Amazon I
kind of think he's got his act together
you you have certain things to grab on
to to say I'm going to I'm going to do
this this research to make my investment
here it's it's a little bit more
abstract right as far as uh you know how
do I pick which coins you know 90% of
the the websites I've seen for these
applications and I'm somewhat educated
around the space um you know on a scale
of 1 to 10 I get myself a solid four or
five but I'm not on the engineering side
but you go to the it and it's just all
of this Tech
jargon and that tells me that they're
not in touch with solving a mass
consumer problem they're in touch with
building something that they think is
really cool right and that's not really
an asset that I want to invest in so wow
so uh now if people are out there saying
okay I'm not a sophisticated investor um
but uh you know I I kind of do the
traditional stuff uh but this is
interesting to me what's the p path they
would take to try to you know say okay I
need to get up the speed to be able to
properly invest
here yeah you know buying it today is
easier than ever uh there's the cash app
there's coinbase which is super easy and
so I think that's becoming more and more
accessible at this point it's how do you
use it safely so there are just you know
a lot of sophisticated scams out there
where even if you take some really good
security steps and you set up two Factor
authentication on your phone uh but if
you do it via SMS text let's say where
you get a text back and you have to
enter in your your code right to verify
your your login there are employees at
these phone companies that are paid for
and bought by the crooks and they'll
switch out your your sim card give your
number you know control over your phone
number to the crook for 5 10 minutes in
order for them to get that
authentication number switch it back and
you wake up and your crypto's gone um
and there's no way to recover it at that
point is it no it's gone yeah yeah so
you know there are just pieces around
around like that that people need to get
educated on we're seeing the big the big
next wave here is going to be with the
introduction of essentially you know
Wall Street uh institutions into this
industry we're see we're seeing back
launch this year um we're seeing the
what is that uh back
is a joint venture I believe between
Microsoft and and a couple of other
really large Fortune 500 companies to
bring institutional level infrastructure
to crypto and a part of that is
insurance right so nobody's going to put
in pension fund money into anywhere if
it's not going to be insured against
theft right and so all of those pieces
of infrastructure being put in place
right now this year and I think once
those come online and they get approval
from the SEC that's when you see this
turn
into yeah you know days in a really big
way and for me this industry and I just
tell people straight up it's speculation
mhm we are speculating we're gambling
and our odds are really really good but
at the same time more than anything else
you have to have an Exit Plan uh on what
you're going to do with potential gains
if we see another 100x move what are you
going to do with that money and I think
that's a really important question to
ask as well uh and it's just also really
important for people to understand that
this is unbelievably risky right now it
is super early and so making sure that
you don't invest money that you can't
afford to lose is a huge huge part of
this and I think a lot of people
unfortunately learned that lesson in
2017 yeah you know so so uh for you um
do you see yourself focusing mostly in
this area for the perceivable future as
far as your business
activities no um you know the the focus
for me really remains around
entrepreneurship I think that's my my
biggest point of value in what I can
offer people because that's where I've
learned the most lessons during my
career uh I think making people aware of
crypto in the basics is a role that I
can play but it's not it's not my field
um I think I think I have a talent for
taking complex subjects and
communicating them to other people in a
simple manner which is helpful in you
know to a large group of people but
that's that's my role so uh well let's
go back to that for a moment because uh
you know you almost became a dentist or
at least had an interest early on
because as you said the you the the the
most wealthy person in your family tree
was a dentist let's say somebody
actually went and did that and now they
they've practiced for 25 30 years and
they said I can't do another decade or
two of this uh I want to become an
entrepreneur you know I I've saved some
money so I'm not like you know starving
and going to live in a locker but you
know uh but I I now want to make a move
what do you think in today's world the
best move is for somebody like that you
know it comes back to skill sets it
comes back back to it's not about your
idea it's not about how much money you
can plow into it it's about your skill
set and for me the primary skill set is
on the the sales
side you can have a phenomenal product
you can be a world-class engineer if you
can't sell either your you know your
backers from an investment standpoint or
your team from a hiring standpoint or at
the end of the day your customers
doesn't matter so my biggest piece of
advice around that is is understand what
your skill set is and how that can be
applied in a way that'll help grow a
business and generate revenue revenue is
the lifeblood of a
business business gets unbelievably
stressful if money's not coming in the
door especially if you start to build a
team and um you know your expenses get
up there so that to me is skill set
number one until you have that don't
worry about it Go learn how to sell how
to how to Market how to generate leads
how to generate traffic once you can do
that the world your oyster you can do
anything because you can apply that
skill set to absolutely anything in any
industry that inspires you and that's
really the key to to success these days
and I don't know of a single
entrepreneur who has had success without
learning that and acquiring that skill
set either at one point or another it
really has served as the foundation for
all of us so do you have dispositions
toward you know real estate versus
buying a franchise versus uh you know
trading the market uh you know one of
the biggest
lessons that I've learned is when I was
young I always
remember asking myself where's the
greatest point of Leverage M and what
would that mean when you say greatest
point of Leverage yeah where's the
greatest point of Leverage where's my
goal and so back in the network
marketing industry this is what I was
thinking about like okay I'm a
distributor and I'm building maybe
a a network of people who might consume
the products or might sell them as well
but my point of Leverage is their
activity and their consumption MH so I
might have a group of three or 400 500
people below me who are buying products
or maybe they're building a business as
well but that's my point of Leverage off
of their activity what's the next level
up of Leverage it's the uh the company
owner right they're getting paid on
everybody's activity and
consumption where's the next point of
Leverage from there well maybe it's as a
software company that is serving all of
the network marketing companies maybe
it's providing merchant services to them
maybe it's providing you know customer
management software accounting software
whatever it may be where's the next
point of Leverage up from that software
company it's probably the bank who's
providing them liquidity and funding
right so same with real estate if you
were going to get into real estate today
if you're starting out maybe you're
going to be an agent and you're going to
go sell homes and at that point you're a
really hardworking salesperson but
there's no leverage so what's the next
level up well maybe you own The
Brokerage that has 10 agents fantastic
you look at Keller Williams and you know
what they're doing multi billion dollar
real estate company I think top three in
the world and I've had lunch with Gary a
couple times and and Gary's in a great
point of Leverage he's got 150,000
200,000 agents underneath him basically
making him money every day and so after
that where's the greatest point of
Leverage again it's the banking system
it's providing the mortgages and loans
for all of these homes that are being
sold so a question that I would ask
yourself whenever you're thinking about
starting a business you're not going to
be able to start at that top at that
greatest point of Leverage but what is
it and at least think about it right and
to me that would be my goal uh is to One
Day end up there at that point because
that's the difference between making you
know $250,000 a year and $250 million a
year uh but at least be aware of it and
and look for it so leverage basically be
defined it's getting things done through
other people sure yeah so uh and I think
that that was a great stair stepping
example saying hey if you're the
salesperson you're you're hustling all
the time and you're just you eat what
you kill as compared to saying now I got
other people hunting for me and and they
all feed a piece up to you upstream and
those are two different skill sets
making that transition is has been the
hardest one for me to make and it
typically is for most entrepreneurs the
skills that'll allow you to make your
first million dollars essentially
sales it's completely different when all
of a sudden you can no longer sell and
you've got a team of 10 12 people that
now have to take over that role and
responsibility because you developed a
lot of skill and talent and Nuance when
it came to producing the results that
you did and all of a sudden you've got
to say okay I can't do that anymore I've
got to teach these these other group of
people how to take that over that's a
huge transition and it's uh it's it's
starting over in many ways for for an
entrepreneur what uh what books uh uh or
any kind of media have influenced you
most that you think you found most
beneficial to your life you know the
traditional thinking Grow Rich I don't
when friends and influenc people way
back in the day that's what I was
reading in college on the floor Barns &
Noble
and you know out of out after that
there's a lot of great books from Dan
Kennedy on Direct response marketing I
think Dan's a great teacher and and his
principles are applicable to any
industry after that it really has just
transitioned into to Leverage and
scaling from a Phil philosophical
standpoint obviously atas Shrugged um
you know we've that's been a huge
inspiration in my life and it was really
interesting specifically in 20072 2008
having read that book and watch watching
what was happening around the world it
was almost as if straight out of the
pages right and it's still happening
yeah
um you know rocket fuel is from a
scaling standpoint a phenomenal little
book to help you as an entrepreneur or
make that transition and get to a point
of essentially working on your business
instead of in it um the emth is where
that line came from so my home is filled
with hundreds of books I'd say I've
probably read half of them the others
the others are still on the to-do list
right and are you finding you that
there's a lot of blogs that maybe are
beneficial too as compared to just books
but there's other forms of of content
out there that you can go get you know
interestingly enough I think that's the
biggest challenge young entrepreneurs
have today is they're growing up with
Instagram and 15c Story videos and five
minute videos on YouTube and Twitter and
blog
posts and it's more information than
ever MH with less value than
ever and for me I found that success is
in the details I found that if I will
focus on acquiring a piece of knowledge
or skill that I spend a year on and
maybe read five books on or three ring
binders on or go to conferences on and I
get down to a level where I'm debating
which word I should use out of a
document that has 10,000 words because I
know that word is going to make a
difference that's the difference between
success and not and I don't think
specifically young entrepreneurs these
days really understand that and so they
wonder why they're watching hours of
content a day and still not
accomplishing anything so for me I view
it as a as a negative in many ways
especially if you're just starting out
you're much better served reading a book
that's 200 300 pages long from end to
end you're going to come out of that
with a real set of understanding and
skills rather than you know a 10-page
blog post yeah and I that's what I've
noticed is that depth is important and
and it's it's that extra little few
percent of of knowledge that is The
Tipping Point as to success versus
failure that's what separates you you
know as an expert as compared to
somebody who's kind of an amateur um
success is in the details yeah really is
so uh I'm I'm an admirer of self-made
man for a lot of reasons I think we
always share some of the common roots
and our philosophies and what's
influenced us and uh so just the title
caught me when I saw a self-made man I
actually own that that sculpture uh tell
me about it and where you're going with
it you know self-made man was was
inspired at a Tony Robbins event I went
to date with Destiny in
2014 and I was at a transition point in
my career in my life where I built two
successful companies and I needed a new
challenge um and I wasn't sure exactly
what to do yet but I I knew of two
problems that I was aware of that I
thought I could solve one was in the uh
food production industry and this is a
bit of a rabbit hole but I live right
across the street from the headquarters
of whole Foods here in Austin Texas and
Shop in the produce section every day do
a lot of juicing and if you do some
juicing at Whole Foods you're walking
out with $60 $70 worth of produce it's
not cheap and it really bothered me that
you have to be fairly wealthy in the
United States just to buy food that is
not covered in Poison right and I
thought that was really screwed up so I
had an idea to essentially solve that
problem and I wanted to put clean
organic food in everybody's home at a
price they could afford so I actually
went out and bought a bunch of books on
hydroponics on Amazon
and uh started to make notes and come up
with ideas on how to solve this and
fairly simply put it had to produce
enough food for you and your family on a
a monthly basis that would replace your
run to the grocery store had to be easy
so that everybody could use it you don't
have to have any knowledge of plants and
it had to be pretty because it's going
to be in your house so I've never never
developed a physical product never
really grown anything definitely not
dove into Tech or
Hydroponics so it started on Amazon with
a few books and a few phone calls to
some industrial design firms and I had a
little mockup made on Photoshop on odesk
I paid a goty 200 bucks to take this
idea and make a little photo of
it and a couple of months later we
signed on with a phenomenal firm in
Silicon Valley and we're going to make
the first automated farm for your house
that'll grow all your food and the idea
is how do we decentralize the a industry
because if you get rid of the farm and
the farmer and the tractor and the 18
wheelers and the Thousand Miles of
highway or the massive tankers that
float from continent to continent and if
you get rid
of the pesticides and the distribution
centers and finally the retail Center
guess what your food goes down 90% you
get rid of 100% of the pesticides and
the
pollution and everything starts and ends
in your in your
kitchen uh but no one had really ever
done that before on a consumer level
space you can find little countertop
systems you can use to grow some basil
or mint but that was about it so we
built it we built it about 2 and a half
years we built a system that would grow
about $4,000 a year worth of food and
for 400 bucks and fully automated you
just drop in the seed and the lights
take care of everything else and the
nutrients and the dosing and the pH
balancing and all of that and it was
phenomenal but it uh almost bankrupted
me so so that was a big lesson learned
because I funded all of it and right as
we were getting to a point where okay
we've got a prototype working what do we
do next this was my lesson learned in
lack of skill set in this industry uh
you know how much longer is this going
to take well probably through safety
testing development package
design you know service centers another
two years another two three million
bucks I was like oh crap because when we
first started this you know the budget
was $500,000 at least that was the
estimate we were way beyond that at that
point and so I hit a point where I
essentially had to go raise money or
pull the plug on it and I ended up
talking to a mentor of mine asking him
for advice and he said look for a win or
a way to win in this even though it
might not look like the initial road
that you had intended mhm can you do
anything with your competitors and so I
called up a competing company who had
just launched a phenomenal line of
products that were like ours they were
had a y combinator had a ton of money
big team and I ended up investing in
them and I pulled the plug on on
evergrow which was the company at the
time and the backup plan after that was
self-made man and the other problem that
I took away from Tony's event was the
fact that I've seen at least a huge
decay in the value system here in the
United States from Washington and Wall
Street on down now it's get the result
you want at any cost whether you have to
lie cheat or steal and there was not a
lot of Pride being taken in
craftsmanship and quality and work ethic
it was just where's my
money and I thought that that was going
to lead to a really nasty place here in
the US a generation from now you look at
how many young men specifically are
growing up without dads and Role Models
really bad situation
straight out
shrug so the backup plan was how can
we elicit change on a society level uh
you know Paradigm essentially over a
generation or two and looking back in
history I've really only found that
there's two ways to do that it's through
the barrel of a gun as many dictators
have done or it's by indoctrinating the
kids and the Next Generation with a
different value set right so obviously
for me I went that route and and the
goal for self-made man is to really
provide young men with mentors and
Leadership and an education set and a
philosophy of life that will uh you know
lead them to become really productive
honest members of society and that was
the goal and it really took on a life of
its own how long has it been out there
now we launched the podcast in the end
of 2014 beginning of 2015 and that's
really all it was at the time I'm going
to do a weekly show with amazing people
MH and then this year 2018 we launched
the education platform that we've been
building and essentially it's an online
school for for young men with ambition
is basically the audience that we we are
targeting or if you're 18 frankly to 40
and you have ambition and you want to
achieve something more in life we want
to provide you with the mentorship and
the knowledge you need to accomplish
that so so is the way just go selfmade
man.com and people can you find the
podcast and other materials there yeah
how rewarding is has this been for you
yeah I mean it's hard to be getting just
a little message from from someone who
is like man you're just listening to the
podcast sent me down a new Direction in
life and here's where I was before and
here's where I am today and that's
really my goal is uh you know I had a I
had a pretty vivid dream recently where
there was a bunch of pictures of
families on the wall that I was looking
at and they were all super happy and
stoked and and feeling uh just like
they're were they were meant to be and
those were all of the families whose
lives essentially had changed Direction
because they were exposed to what we're
building and so for me that that's you
know what I'm after so after all these
years now that you put into your
entrepreneurial career um are you
finding growth in your fulfillment uh
are you finding that's waning or there's
burnout how you feeling about it all now
you know the longer I pursue my career
as an entrepreneur the more I realize I
don't know
and evergrow is a perfect lesson for
that where I like to call I paid a
really high stupid tax you pay the tax
and you're going to pay the tax in one
form or another you're either going to
pay it because you're going to go out
and buy courses and education and
acquire the knowledge you need to pursue
what you're building or you're going to
pay in the form of mistakes time and
money lost there's no avoiding it but
one choice is better than the other and
so you know the more I challenge myself
the the more lessons I learn and and
I've still got a hell of a long way to
go so yeah yeah one of my premises or
saying saying around this is that the
great thing about entrepreneurs is that
they fall in love with their ideas but
the problem with entrepreneurs is that
they fall in love with their ideas yeah
that was a big part of evergrow yeah was
learning that and and getting a lot of
pieces of pieces of wisdom around that
from others who'd gone through that and
thankfully I was I was willing to listen
to him so we've covered a lot of ground
uh it's been uh really really
stimulating uh any final thoughts you
know the biggest the biggest lessons
I've learned again
are if you're stuck and you want to
become unstuck and make progress Go
Master a new skill set to the point
where you can write a book on it the
point where you can provide that service
or skill set to other people you know as
a as a service provider at that point
you can open so many doors but as long
as you keep reading about that and not
doing it you're going to stay where
you're at
second piece of advice would be to
really master your emotions when it
comes to money because making money and
keeping money are two very different
skill sets and that's another another
lesson I've had to learn through my
career as well so start to study that
now start to assume that you've got a
million dollars in the bank and start to
make a plan for it and to decide how
you're going to use it uh and then
finally when you have anide idea for a
solution that can help a lot of people
once again look for that greatest point
of Leverage and know from day one that
in order to ascend to that point it's
going to be all about people it's going
to have to your skill set is going to
have to change from creating or selling
your product to building a team and and
really growing a great group of people
and becoming a leader and just keep that
in mind as well great advice great
wisdom thanks so much for taking the
time to sit and share it with us yeah
absolutely thanks for having
[Music]
I'm sure you enjoyed part one of my
interview with Economist Paul Zan pser
riveting information now Paul is going
to share some strategies with you about
where he puts his own money what his
thoughts are about how to take existing
wealth and grow it and create cash flow
from it he's done it so it's not
abstract it's something he's actually
put on the ground and made work in his
own life and I I think it's very
compelling so enjoy my part two
interview with Paul
zzer Paul thanks for sitting down with
us again I'm really looking forward to
continuing our conversation thank you
it's always great to be here with you
Patrick so you're the only person in the
world who's ever made economics
completely fascinating to me so you know
just whenever you were giving
presentations giving your lectures you
know you really have these very
stimulating thoughts about the economy
and you kind of talk about varying
aspects of Economics that when you're
read them in in uh you professional
papers they seem very boring but when
you talk about them they seem very uh
how could I put it applicable to my life
so now what I want to talk about and
it's something that I've been watching
you do you over the past years is saying
hm if I've got some money to invest and
I need to create cash flow in my life
like what are some ways to do that you
yourself I guess we talk about the fact
that you owned some Planet Fitness
franchises for example what was it that
caused you to say you know what I'm
gonna I'm GNA go invest in some of these
franchises and create cash flow from
that well frankly I like most things it
was happen stance or I calling a happy
accident that got me to Planet Fitness
so let me tell you how I got into Planet
Fitness then we'll come back to your
main question which is uh why Planet
Fitness versus other businesses um in
1991 I didn't know this I was on Larry
King live TV show that I knew and
watching was the founder of Planet
Fitness but wasn't yet the plan founder
of Planet Fitness he was a person with a
frankly dying gym mhm and he watched me
went out and bought my book unlimited
wealth and used that book as a Bible his
friend's joke it's the only book he ever
read and he used that book is this Bible
and built Planet Fitness into a then 200
store chain of Fitness chain gyms M and
it was fascinating model how he built
Planet uh at the time every gym had an
average of about, 1500 members members
Gold's Gym 24-Hour Fitness you remember
the gyms that were around B and at 1500
members you barely break even right if
you can get to 1600 1700 1,800 is all
profit because it's a heavy fixed cost
business right and that was the gym
business mhm and he figured out not
mathematically like I did later on but
he figured out that the right business
was to build a gym for 8,000 members
don't fight with every other gym going
1500 1600 retool the whole Engineering
Process of the gym from signing on the
customers using modern technology and
iPads make it paperless make all the
money collection paper list called
electronic funds transfer from your
checking account and he built Planet
Fitness in a very successful business W
in 2010 he had his first convention in
Las Vegas and he was very excited to be
bringing together the 200 franchises he
had gone around the country and
recruited he said you know I want for my
keynote speaker I want Paul pser so he
hired me as the speaker and I got very
involved with the company I thought it
was a terrific model people could join a
gym for 10 bucks a month and do
something about their Wellness very
exciting model but then once I became
known for Planet Fitness as the speaker
at their convention and all that goes
viral and I'm all over the web as
someone speaking about Planet Fitness
people start coming up to me and my
family members and saying wow Paul owns
Planet Fitness and my wife would say no
we don't own Planet Fitness Paul's just
a paid speaker but that didn't matter
for everyone she told that to there were
thousands of people who thought Paul 's
Planet Fitness cuz he's all over the web
speaking about Planet
Fitness I said to my wife Lisa you got
me nervous here they're using my name
they're using my likeness I like the
company but I don't know anything about
it they've been inviting me for a year
now to come visit them at their
headquarters in New Hampshire why don't
you take off fly to New Hampshire meet
the management team meet more important
some of the franchises and make sure
this is legitimate she goes great takes
off in New Hampshire she comes back she
bought a fstore area development
agreement for Salt Lake City without
consulting you build stores well she
made the deal and signed it but she saw
an opportunity and said this is a great
business right people want to lose
weight and they need an affordable gym
that's honest and lets them quit any
time right no commitment 10 bucks a
month what could be simpler right that's
how I got into the Planet Fitness Gyms
wow so Planet Fitness is exciting to me
as a mathematician and Economist because
of the way in which the business works
if you remember back in high school when
you studied quadratic equations there
were two solutions and one was
considered a ridiculous solution and one
was the right solution and you had to
look at which one was practical and
throw out the wrong solution I've always
looked at the wrong solution which is
mathematically correct solves the
problem as maybe that's the answer and a
good example of a wrong solution would
be Galileo who looked up at the heavens
back in the time of Galileo what could
you possibly believe if you looked
outside except that the Earth is the
center of the universe and the Sun comes
up over here and revolves this way
around the earth right and the moon and
all the planets revolve around the
stationary Earth it's wrong but it's so
obvious and it became our calendar for
5,000 years till Galileo invented the
telescope and proved that wrong
similarly in a lot of businesses in
mathematics everybody's trying to
linearly grow and in plan of Fitness in
the gym business people trying to grow
from 1500 members a club to, 1550 to
1600 and the right answer is throw
everything you know out about running
A500 member Club retool the whole
organization for 8 to 10,000 members
then go out and get 8 to 10,000 members
in your gym by low price honest stealing
and all the good things that go with
Planet Fitness so as an economist and a
speaker I was interested in Planet
Fitness and became much more interested
when my wife started to say we're going
to open gyms in our business here in
Utah where we live and we're going to
use this as a model she said to teach
our children that retail stores and
businesses don't just exist somebody
takes a piece of land builds a building
RS to the people and really works very
hard to give someone a great experience
but personally as a head of household
which is actually what Economist means
economics literally means a household
and economics is a study of a head of
household or a householder back in
biblical times I had no idea it's first
ever heard that the word Greek economics
means household or manager of a
household wow okay so I'm also in
addition to being an economist and a
speaker I'm a householder I have to pay
bills like everybody else I have to
worry that I'm going to make enough
money going forward for four children
who are now in high school to go off to
college I have to worry about where I
might live when I retire and make
investments and as a head of household
or as a business person I like Planet
Fitness very much because it's primarily
a cash flow business you open a business
like Planet Fitness you invest roughly
about $2.5 million to 3 million in a
store and if everything goes well and it
works which most of them obviously do uh
you're going to make about a million
dollars cash flow year something they
say in their offering last I saw 600,000
to 800,000 but a good successful
operator I know can make about a million
a year profit per store okay and I had
never had businesses like that being a
tech entrepreneur and an economist I had
always built businesses that served a
customer with a product and Along Came
somebody who wanted it more than I did
or I wanted to play with some other toys
and they said we'll buy this from you
right so my life financially since I
left City Bank in 1981 that was my last
salary last time I got a monthly check
to live on was 1981 right when I left
City bank and went out on my own as an
entrepreneur and For Better or Worse all
of my businesses as an entrepreneur were
about initially real estate buying some
land Building something getting it
leased up and before I could enjoy it
somebody would offer me more money than
I thought it was worth and I would take
the money and go off and do something
else so my career from 1981 till 2010
was all about building businesses not
owning businesses planet was very
different
planet was a successful franchise then
with 200 stores today about 1500 stores
wow and planet was a business that you
primarily invested for good cash flow
very taxable but cash flow you put in
two and a half million and you can earn
roughly a 35 to 45% return in monthly
cash flow and that was exciting to me
and something that fit the time of my
life because I started entering my 60s
I'm 64 years old today and look at
businesses is not what will this
business do for the future 10 20 years
from now what will this business do next
year next year next year because I like
having cash flow coming in and planet
was really the first business I ever did
that brought me current cash and that
opened up a whole new world of investing
because investing to me was always about
growth and multiplying 2 3 4X your
capital and this is what's interesting
so you make a distinction between uh
phases of life and type of investment
that would come kind of match with where
you are absolutely and that's what we in
E economics call the utility curve
utility curve let's assume you and I are
identical we certainly have the same
hairstyle we certainly have kids who
love each other we have lots of things
in common right but how would two smart
people do business together if we have
so much in common what are we going to
bring to the table well you might have
10 apples and I have 10 oranges you see
right away how even though we're
identical in thinking we value
everything the same you don't value
oranges the same I value Apples because
we can do a switch right and a utility
curve is in oodles literally we use the
word udle how much you value each
additional Apple if you got 10 not many
you want an orange but once you got 10
oranges you want more apples and utility
curves are the reason the economy works
it's the reason very smart people from
the same background with the same money
will all do business together and want
to trade and one do labor work for the
other you might want to clean the
kitchen I might want to clean the den we
might want to own this car I might want
a convertible and we swap and all of
that works into the economy because
people who are similarly situated have
different utility curves and so with age
or phases of Life those utility curves
change absolutely when I'm younger all I
want to think about is how do I grow and
make money right um some people in the
younger ages say I just want to make
money and spend it right and they have a
very good life when they're young but
often not a very good life when they're
40 50 60 years old and they haven't
saved up money now and so what I find
interesting is what you're saying and I
think this is you I'm witnessing this
myself because it's like you the idea of
putting money in investing letting it
accumulate and cash out you know at a at
a multiple some years down the road now
you're saying hm if I put up this type
of a thing in this case a franchise and
I I'm going to take cash that I have
accumulated over years put it into a
franchise and then every month I'm
getting money that literally if I'm not
working I still have income coming in
every month from that investment I made
and then you multiply investment with
multiple franchises and actually turns
into maybe more money you made than you
when you were working the key in to
investing once you're an adult or even
say over 30 or 40 is the term harvesting
M when are you going to harvest your
crop yeah so if you're going to start a
business and you're younger I'm willing
to wait 10 20 years because I fully
expect young people think they're
Invincible I'll be around at 64 today
the first thing I look at when I look at
investment is what's the likely time
Horizon for when this investment will
return me either current cash flow or
residual cash flow after it's sold or
cash flow from growing the business and
selling it to someone else and
harvesting time has become an all
important criteria for me I invest in
funds where other people pull my money
with other money and do great things but
the first thing I want to know is this
fund got a 10-year horizon or a 20-year
Horizon if it's a long-term land
development project I'm investing in it
might have three before decade Horizon
now I also have four kids who right now
I'm not too focused on their residual I
got to get them to high school and get
them to college but at some point if
they were my business partners and
they're 30 years old I might think oh
I'll go back to taking a long-term
Horizon because I don't need the money
but my children might want it but that's
for the future but you start to see that
you should be driven by your family
situation what do you need to live on
what do you need today what is your
spouse need what is your partner need
what do your children need do you have
any special needs children and then
project that forward over a likely
lifespan and do you see how that's going
to be the most important criteria the
time return for harvesting and making an
investment as you AG you're the first
person I I heard say that because I
think that's a critical consideration
because a lot of people say you know
they have different models of investing
here's my investing advice here's how I
think you should do it and certainly
people talk about uh you know levels of
risk and and and you know Harvest Time
as far as you know what age are you and
here's what I'd recommend Etc but you're
almost starting from the value
standpoint of saying wait a minute I'm a
human being with a family and if I've
got kids in the in in their 30s and we
want to create some kind of a family
business with the money that I've
accumulated that's a strong
consideration as to the decisions I
would make as compared to my kids are
off doing their own thing and successful
in their own right and I you I've got a
separate thing or I have no kids all
those are are really considerations so
there's not like who has the best
investment advice it's starting by
saying what are my circumstances and
what's applicable to me based on the
circumstances we really learned that as
a civilization in the post Baby Boom
years prior to the baby boom we're
including most of the baby baby boom
it's about making money what do you do
when you make a lot of money dad I make
more money and what do you do I make
more money it sounds crazy yeah and the
baby boom was the first generation
between rock music and all the things
that we love doing that said maybe I
don't want to make just more money maybe
I want to do something environmentally
sound and make a little less money maybe
I want to make money now more cash flow
maybe I want to save for the future even
though I'm not spending it I sleep real
well at night and the baby boomer really
started applying utility curves to them
and their children all the way to the
Millennials that we might argue
completely apply utility curves without
thinking of how they're going to pay
bills because they got a rich baby
boomer Dad or Mom to take care of them
right so we really need to identify
First who are we and our stage in life
when you're about to do an investment
most important before you worry about
how much and how you make money when are
you going to make money right the most
important thing if you invest money now
and I'm talking anyone over 30 when does
Harvest Time come around remember the
sooner it harvests the less risk right
but guess what the sooner it Harvest
probably the less return right and you
need to quantify that and figure out
your time Horizon of investing before
you figure out how you going to invest
how you're going to manage your money
and bring happiness because ultimately
money is really not about gross domestic
product and increasing it's about gross
naal happiness and gross national
happiness is a defined term by the
United Nations they spend 180 million a
year collecting the data that goes into
a database each year to determine which
countries are happy but as we look
around it's which people are happy which
children of ours are happy which of our
friends and relatives are and how do we
get them more happier and you start to
see how utility curves time Horizon to
invest all enter into a new formula
we're entering into called I want more
gross national happiness or gross
domestic happiness to be more accurate
versus I just want to make money right
so now and that's another interesting
thing saying okay it's the what do I
invest in but of course the the when you
know when do I harvest is another
question and then the why means like
what are my values like as you're saying
maybe I also care about the environment
it's so you know let's call it the
Legacy side of it you there's some maybe
Legacy issues that are important to you
so uh so it's not as simple as just
saying oh follow this Guru and do what
they say because they know the right
thing it's it's different for everybody
right and what we also see is a
reemergence of the franchise business
and once I got into Planet Fitness I
started looking around at other
franchises and I found that plan it was
not unique there were many other
franchise businesses that had developed
a formula had continual R&D and that
were attractive in the past I've always
been the entrepreneur who started a
business I literally took a blank slate
building I invented it I drew it out on
paper I had a lot of fun doing it and
built a business some of them worked
some of them didn't this stage in my
life I don't have time for that I need a
business that tell show me the thousands
of people who have done it show me the
thousands of people who have made it
work for them and then take their
situation and I'm not going to copy them
I'm not going to reinvent the wheel I'm
going to license it and that's really
where the franchise business comes in
our world changes so fast today and the
product you make and the customer you
have changes so fast with the internet
you used to open a store and it was on a
certain Street and your loyalty with
your customers coming by and if your
product wasn't so great after a while
they still came by they told you and you
had time to fix it today with the
internet if there's a better product for
your customer you're lucky if you last a
nanc before somebody clicks on that
product versus your product you've got
to have a huge R&D Department in almost
every business to stay on top of your
customer not just serve your existing
customer and that's where I've come to
really enjoy franchises like Planet
Fitness who today I think the stock
price is about $4.8 billion uh we had an
IPO of about roughly a billion half
dollars two years ago it's now trading
at about 4.8 wow and more important the
company spends on new products new
services and always brings them in so
our Planet Fitness operators can just
run their gym and know at convention
time when they come together once a year
or just daily because they get an email
from corporate it's going to talk about
new things we're exploring that might
work in your gym new things on trial you
might want to be the whole company is
really a big R&D Department to make sure
we stay ahead with the latest technology
and that you see behind the scenes in
any business you go into go into any
fast food Outlet any item it's not just
the items changing it's the technology
of delivering it it's their sources my
son just took a job he's at 16 years old
at Starbucks I am overwhelmed by the
technology at Starbucks that goes into
training him monitoring him the values
they're teaching him they've got whole
programs and videos for every possible
situation he had to learn how to serve
de people people and he says next week
I'm going to learn how to serve deaf and
blind people these are amazing life
experiences I should pay Starbucks for
what they're delivering to my 16
year-old son but the learning experience
is amazing and there's no way if I own
my own coffee place I could add that
much to environment hire a bright 16
yearold kid and teach him how to serve
people yeah and with the whole franchise
approach you the franchises you own are
sellable right I mean it's it's not like
you just get cash flow and then it burns
out it's like somebody can come in and
say I still want to buy that business
yes and no they're absolutely salable
but I noticed so far my observation I
haven't studied this as an economist
I've studied this as a business person
looking for good business opportunities
for myself and hopefully one day my
children and what I see is that my
high-tech business which is always built
on growth when I go to sell my typical
exits are 20 to 40 times cash flow so if
I'm earning a nickel they'll pay me a
dollar for that business right not that
they want to earn a nickel the new owner
right well let's get real specific here
I build a business for a million
dollarss it's making 50 Grand a year 5%
somebody buys it for 10 $2 million it's
earning down them 2 and a half% but they
think it's growing very fast right with
franchise businesses and Retail
businesses for some reason I don't have
any defined reason why the multiples are
not uh 0.005 cap rate which means you
sell a 20 times your your cash flow
they're more like three four five times
you sell a business for five five times
cash flow I think that's because retail
businesses require an intense amount of
effort on behalf of the owner they
require an amazing diligence and You
Take Your Eye Off the Ball it drops fast
the customer doesn't tell you we had a
bad meal my father taught me when I had
a bad meal to politely ask the person is
the manager here better yet come by
during the day when they're not crowded
and tell the manager I've enjoyed this
place for years we had a bad meal I'm
not here to complain I want you to fix
it before something happens and I was
brought up that that's what a
businessman does for another businessman
today nobody cares you have a bad meal
just think of the last deal that didn't
meet expectations or product yeah
they're getting one star reviews on
Google and or no reviews or no reviews
till the customers all go away yeah and
so we start to seees retail business is
something that you've got to focus on
and most franchises maybe because
someone's done a lot of the intellectual
property work you're lucky if you can
get out at five times now the good news
during the 10 years you might own and
run it you're earning 20% on your money
yeah and you can borrow money at 10% or
11% pay off interest on your the money
you borrowed and still earn 20% on the
total amount of money or 30% so the
franchise businesses let you get the
cash flow earlier but don't have the
amazing residuals when you go to sell
yeah not not the Big Exit but I but at
the same time like if I were consider uh
somebody said well maybe I'll buy real
estate I'll buy an apartment building
and I'll collect rent every month but
the cash flow on that rent relative to
the investment you put in I don't think
it's anything close to what you're
describing in a franchise and maybe the
real estate would go up in value a lot
maybe it wound who knows but if you're
still saying hey I'm going to I'm going
to sell this thing for more for much
more than what it cost me to put it up
and I collected all this cash along the
way that seems like a a pretty
attractive way to to to go for people
who are looking who've worked hard for
some period of years or has maybe maybe
it's an inheritance you know parents di
like left some money saying what do I do
with this seems like an attractive way
to to generate well some people like to
refer to as passive income I never think
it's totally passive but it's it's not
you having to go to work every day to
for a paycheck type well franchises
really are most franchise businesses
which in generally means most retail
businesses or businesses that serve
things like cleaning houses or cleaning
build Office Buildings or some type of
franchise business where someone
developed a model they require an
intense amount of focus by the
entrepreneur individual franchise owner
if they didn't the parent company would
never sell you one right if Planet
Fitness could have built 1,600 corporate
stores all owned by that wonderful guy
Mike back in New Hampshire he would have
done it but he found the most important
criteria to making a successful gym was
the owner the manager who sits there and
hires the best people makes his
employees learn everyone's name and
builds a family business around an
individual gym and he found the only way
he could grow that was making everyone
is partner in a franchise environment
and that's why you will rarely see a
franchise that doesn't require despite
what people tell you a lot of Hands-On
work how many hours a week do you spend
right now on uh you know in your two
franchises well I don't but my wife goes
there virtually every day oh really okay
but she enjoys going there every day she
walks around the gym she talks to people
how are you and they say great and how
do you like Planet Fitness oh I love it
and what who are you oh well my family
she says owns this particular franchise
wow I love it and she loves the karma
she gets she makes a lot of money at it
that's the byproduct of serving Society
if you serve a product to someone very
well and make them very happy trust me
you'll make a lot of money the moment
you take your eye off the product and
the End customer and how much they're
enjoying it the moment you don't get
really upset when someone has a bad
experience in your business get out of
the business because it's going to kick
you
out it's an interesting term it's going
to kick you out you brought up one of my
other areas I think is ripe for huge
investment opportunity and that's real
estate but not necessarily the real
estate you think of most people think of
real estate like you buy an apartment
building you buy some type of commercial
space tenant shows up and just sit there
for collecting coupons for the next 20
years no longer the reason is that the
real estate needs of people are changing
I recently became a significant investor
in funds that invest in senior housing
and a typical senior housing project is
about 110 apartments under 12 apartments
that seniors who are moving out of the
Town might be Allentown Pennsylvania or
some area in California where they are
moving to Florida but they no longer
need the big house right but they want
to get an apartment that they can still
see the grandkids from but they also
think because they're 67 years old how
will I age in this apartment how what's
the floor plan like how will I stay here
if I'm ever disabled or my spouse is and
I want to stay together so we start to
see a whole new need arising which no
one is feeling today for senior housing
because it's changing so fast seniors
might say I could live at home till I
die if only I had someone just eight
minutes a day to help me get dressed in
the morning we call that senior assisted
living right and all of that is up for
grabs right now so the funds I invest in
are buying thousands tens of thousands
of senior housing units and I work with
them on a technology committee to how
can we improve senior housing what kind
of products and services would a senior
want the first thing I notice when I go
into a senior housing project is at the
end of the night they have a piece of
paper and they walk down the hall going
Mr gentempo did you take your medicine
tonight Great Click I look at that piece
of paper that should be an iPad cuz
somewhere there's a grandchild or a
child who would love to know Dad took
his medicines at 11:02 p.m. you and I
don't want to know that but we wouldn't
want to know it around our own kids
especially if they don't live with us to
know they took their medicine to know
they had breakfast to know they went
bowling today and so we start to see
just opening up with transparency the
activities of Senior Living to the
people below them meaning to their
children and grandchildren is a huge
business is ripe for the taking that's
one of the things I'm working on now as
a board member and consultant and I see
wide open as we move to housing that
really doesn't exist senior assisted
housing that really adds value for
seniors because then you can up the rent
in a good way and people will be
thrilled to pay it because they're
getting real value for it not just a
place to put Grandma so I know uh from
prior conversations we've had that you
put a lot of money into that uh what's
what's your time Horizon on that one
though um very good point I disagree
with the funds I invested they invest in
a three to six year Horizon they spend
three years they raise typically 50 or
100 million per fund they spend three
years buying apartment Pro senior
projects or whatever our projects are
then they spend turn them around fix
them up add value then spend three years
selling they're very into adding value
and selling I think that's crazy because
we're selling deals at an eight or n%
rate of return I'm earning two or 3% on
T bills at the bank I don't want more
money to earn to two and 3% that was
earning eight or nine and I tell them
hold on to it longer they go not so fast
Paul our business of funds and how we're
known on Wall Street is we give you back
your money every six years there are
other funds that run by different
companies that have a 10 or 20 year
Horizon fortunately or unfortunately I'm
not in them so we keep making our money
every three to six years getting it back
and I keep investing with the same I was
going to say but you at that point it's
kind of nice to get it back because you
can decide do I want to reinvest or I
would like cash now so I don't have to
reinvest at least you have some options
relative to that so real estate um in
the in the ways that you you putting in
real estate funds that are doing things
that are uh you know seemingly a market
match or real estate yourself where you
develop a niche in a neighborhood and
start adding value which might be
converting a small apartment project to
senior housing it might be buying
yourself a house on a particular
neighborhood that fits where people all
go to a church nearby or a synagogue
that people you know who your customer
is the real value coming in real estate
I see is value add investing you buy
real estate any type of Real Estate you
improve it for a specific purpose or
typee of customer and then you sell it
versus the old days of I'm I'm in real
estate I'll buy anything in real estate
those days are gone you've got to know a
market before you go into it and try to
develop some specialty Niche for your
customer so outside of real estate and
uh and franchises any other
considerations that you think are good
Investments for people to consider I
would say all ones all Investments that
you yourself are the person working it
hard generally if it's a business that
uses technology which virtually everyone
does today I like franchises because I
don't think you're going to be able to
invest the time and money and I'd rather
buy I call it buy retail I'd rather pay
top dollar for a really high quality
franchise that I know is going to work
if I play it out then take the risk on
the new startup franchise that someone
like Paul pser might start because they
don't always work out and you get a
higher return but they're very risky at
the very beginning stages so let's give
this
scenario um somebody's coming up on
retirement they're not you know there
yet but it's coming up pretty quickly
old um let's say 50s um you mid-50s uh
they're going to uh they've got some
work life left but they also say you
retirement's coming up and I'm looking
and I I really don't have the resources
to just say I'm going to retire I don't
want to live on Social Security uh what
should they be thinking about well it's
a great time to be asking that question
and the reason is underlying everything
we do today is the sharing economy in
the past I would say this is a person
who likes theater likes things he wants
to do wants to have money for the
enjoyable things of life this is a
person who has certain kind of housing
needs but doesn't have the money to buy
the housing Everything Changes in a
sharing economy mode because all of a
sudden we can share our real estate we
can share our dinners share our areas
with people of like personality of like
interest and add huge value you don't
want money to just go to restaurants you
want have great restaurant experiences
my wife is real foodie but when I go to
restaurant you know what makes the real
experience you it's the person I'm
dining with and telling me about the
wine and we share and we figure it out
that's much more important to adding
value I'm amazed when I look around a
restaurant particularly when I see
someone sitting alone who might be
traveling can't we figure that out yet
with a with a cell phone that there's a
person here who's interested in model
trains seven other boring hobbies that I
think boring he thinks are great has
three kids at this school and wow I've
got so much in common that if we only
could know those things about each other
we'd have fun in a restaurant now the
kids do this well for and sex but it
goes beyond just dating and sex
particularly when you get older you want
to have real meaning for relationships
or great dinner conversations and so the
sharing economy first helps us find
people of like interest then it finds
the restaurant the place we want to go
of like interest and before it even
reveals who's who I know this person
went to my college I pressed a button to
verify that so we're both sharing the
right info and what does he want out of
me companionship on one meal so the
sharing economy has the ability with
technology to deliver so much value ad
at much lower prices because by
definition it's sharing to individuals
but what we see with retired people is
we all have the same needs so once we
focus on it I would tell your friend
who's about to retire to start
chronicling their life hour by hour get
up in the morning and say what did you
do at 4 p.m. what did you think of at
5:00 p.m. what did you think of at 6
p.m. what did you need on the way home
from work at 7 p.m. and then try to
think are there other similarly situated
individuals at my age with my interest
in my local who also might want to share
with me in producing these items for
others or just consuming them for
ourselves because your individual needs
in the sharing economy are the needs of
other similarly situated people and as
you tune into to them you should look at
them as a business opportunity for a
franchise you may want to buy to serve
people in your neighborhood or just
meeting up with people who have common
interests and common goals so for
example you're saying you know there
could be more shared real estate like
saying maybe two people who are getting
ready for retire two couples getting
ready to retire crazy my wife and I love
Singapore and there are many things we
like about it but 30 years ago 50 years
ago when I was just dreaming of going to
work at City Bank I knew about Singapore
Singapore is 12 hours off Eastern
Standard time zone so Singapore has all
these buildings owned by City Bank
Deutsche Bank that run 24 hours a day
all the buildings and Retail runs 24
hours a day the streets are so lit up at
night you leave work at midnight or 2:
in the morning and you go to dinner and
you're going on a beautiful River you
don't even know it's night time and
what's exciting about Singapore is they
use the real estate 168 hours a week we
use our real estate 40 hours a week
think about just the real estate that
you use and how you could share it you
only sleep in it 60 hours a week and
you've got 168 hours we got to figure
out beds and situations where somebody
like a hotel room that rents by the
12-hour cycle not a 24-hour cycle and
you start to see so many opportunities
of using just the real estate we have in
multiple ways here in Utah we have have
a center for American Express it has
10,000 desks you've probably spoken to
people there if you have an American
Express card and wanted help but it
doesn't have in the 10,000 desk 10,000
employees it has 35,000 employees who
come in and work eight hours and then
move off they get off at midnight but
midnight is 8: in the morning or 8:00
P.M in Madagascar where they're Happ to
work with their customers and what's
exciting when you see this American
Express Center you see someone taking a
piece of real estate that was meant to
serve 10,000 desks used very
productively by 35,000 people so as the
Earth turns and someone needs help with
their American Express card or a
merchant needs to know why this charge
didn't go through they pick up the phone
and a person right here in Utah with
their local dial at local language
answers in the guy in Madagascar or
South Korea or Japan and helps them and
we start to see the opportunities to use
what we have multiple multiple hours not
just for ourselves but great business
opportunities to apply that to people
people who are similarly situated and
what we really see is we all want
companionship we want fun we want
friends and the technology world has yet
to really deliver each time I go to a
party somewhere and what makes a great
party for me at my age it's when I meet
someone really interesting and I want to
follow up and once in a while I'm lucky
I go to a party we talk small talk we
talk business and I meet one or two new
people sometimes a friend of yours and
we go wow let's have lunch or dinner but
that only happens when you go over and
introduce me to somebody new and give me
some background on them and probably
told them there's this economist I want
you to meet you put some work into it
and I look at my phone and go somewhere
in the rest of the phones in this room
there's 50 people here that I could have
something in common with and would like
to meet and I don't want to sell them
anything or buy anything from them I
just want to talk about our latest hobby
or something in politics or I love
economics talk about economics but no
one's walking around reading my mind and
their mind and that's some of the future
things coming with technology that will
greatly improve the quality hour by hour
of our personal relationships so Paul as
usual extraordinarily stimulating
conversation very much appreciate your
time any final thoughts before we close
you should always remember that value in
life comes from serving another human
being when you can bring smile to a
child your spouse your friend or
yourself you're happy and what we want
to do is bring more happiness and
business at its root is serving another
human being it's making them happy by
delivering something they want for less
money or time that they could do it
themselves
and when you deliver it and make them
happy that's when you get your reward
and that's what it's so exciting to me
about economics I see this wonderful
world out there of seven and a half
billion people trying to find an edge to
how to serve another human being better
that's what makes economics that's what
drives them to success that's great and
I think in the end that's the moral
virtue of capitalism right is people
serving other people and being rewarded
for doing so so terrific well thanks so
much for being with us thank you Patrick
it's always a
[Music]
pleasure
capitalism.com what a great URL for the
money revealed docu series next up I
have one of the two interviews I did
with Ryan Moran who is the founder and
owner of capitalism.com in this
particular interview he gets tactical on
how to grow successful businesses so if
you don't have a pen and Pad handy right
now you might want to pause and get one
there's going to be a lot of notes that
you can take away from this interview
that will be helpful to you enjoy it so
ran great to have this conversation we
want to get more practical now
strategies how what you see as working
is for people and entrepreneurial
careers or seeking entrepreneurial
careers or even side hustle saying hey
you know I have my normal job but here's
something that you know I'm trying to
look for something on the side to expand
uh my income Etc and you said you've got
a lot of passion around this so tell me
some of your thoughts regarding those
issues yeah this is my jam you would say
so in my my work I basic basically help
people create a plan to get them their
their first million doll business and
have have helped been a part of several
hundred successful businesses um that
have either resulted in people selling
their business or making it their
full-time thing or or or side thing and
the the first thing that we have to
identify here is what we spoke about
previously of disconnecting the idea of
time worked versus money earned right
because ultimately as Jim ran would have
said or did say we're compensated for
the value we bring to the marketplace it
takes time to produce value but we're
not paid for the time we're paid for the
value that we bring to the
marketplace and we can we do that by
doing things that create a scalable
impact throughout the rest of the world
or our world so one of the one of the
ways that we've done this at
capitalism.com is through physical
products Brands the the kind of aha
formula that that a lot of our students
say is when the light bulb came out is
if we have three to five products
selling 20 to 35 units per day at an
average price point of $25 to
$35 that's a million dollar business and
we could run those numbers a couple
different ways but three to five
products selling about 30 sales a day is
about 100 sales a day at an average
price point of about $30 is a million
doll business and that million business
is usually when we have something we can
either scale or something that we can
sell and I believe that the fast lane to
Financial Freedom is to build a business
and invest the profits and if I were to
say the
faster Lane would be to build a business
and sell it and then invest that for
passive income so that you can Define
life on your own terms and for some
people that means you then double down
on another business right and for other
people say I'm done I'm going to now do
what I would like for a few years and
either one is totally cool because
you're responsible for the results that
you get and the way that you pursue
happiness so uh I want to talk about the
blueprint that you have for this uh but
before I do uh I'm going I'm going to
fast forward to one of the things you
just said and then we'll go back um when
you say that okay because let's say I'm
a a dentist I'm 50 years old I've
accumulated a good amount of money but I
want side money or I want to be able to
create passive income maybe I'm starting
to look toward retirement and I I don't
want to just retire my capital and burn
it I want to figure out a way to use
that in a in a way that works in today's
world where it can provide me passive
income what are some of your suggestions
around that I think every single person
should be taking 10% of their take-home
income and automatically placing that
into some sort of a long-term investment
so for me that's just I have ER trade
deduct a certain amount from my checking
account every month and I go and I put
that n dividend paying stock now I would
say I am like in step three of the
process because I've built a business
I've sold businesses I've invested for
enough passive income to where my life
is taken care of and now I'm Investing
For really long-term wealth for some
people if you don't have that side
business that is producing some sort of
exponential return that's the first
investment that I would make to someone
who is
entrepreneurial so if somebody was set
on staying in their job and just
doubling down on their career I would
say okay that's going to be your source
of income let's go to step two and
invest for passive income but for the
person who doesn't want that life or
they want something on the side or they
want the thing to replace their job I'd
say that 10% of your take-home pay needs
to be being set aside for that side
business that is going to ultimately
hopefully create the income that's going
to replace the job that you're working
and the number one thing that you can be
doing with that 10% mhm is to be in
education and learning as much about
business and advertising as possible so
I think that the the hack if you will to
creating income On Demand is by having
an audience is by having people who pay
attention when you distribute
information to them and that can that
can come in the form of a YouTube uh
Channel it can come from a podcast it
can come from a Blog it can come from
people reading your Facebook posts it
can come from an email list it can come
from Facebook Messenger it can come from
Twitter it can come from Pinterest it
can come from Instagram we can go on and
on and on forever so if there are people
even if it's a few hundred people who
actively digest whatever you put into
the world we can turn that into enough
money to do damage and to get to that
first few hundred it'll take a few
dollars and by a few dollars it could be
as simple as 500 or $1,000 for us to put
something onto a channel advertise it to
people who would benefit from it until
we have a few hundred or few th000
people following our work on Facebook
Instagram our blog on and on forever
wherever you're putting your content
that audience is your hack to creating
income on demand and we can go into how
to do that but that is that is like
absolute Foundation step one of how you
create a predictable income stream that
is not tied to anything except the value
you're bringing to
let's go ahead and dig deeper then since
we're on it so uh go ahead and talk
about that a little bit more as far as
saying okay maybe like kind of give a a
scenario so you got this person here's
the amount of money they have to invest
and here's the process yeah so I mean if
somebody has I was asked once if I have
an extra $500 a month what should I do
with it I'd say I'd put it all on
Advertising whatever content you're
producing in the world so if you are a
dentist and your passion is Dentistry
right and you want to have a a business
that serves other dentists then you need
to be putting out content for other
dentists and advertising that on
whatever platform you are most
comfortable Distributing that content
and a lot of people will debate over the
best place is Pinterest the best place
is Facebook no it's Instagram it's now
it's Snapchat some people will say do
all of them I say do whichever one you
naturally do right because you're going
to continue doing that right so for me I
will sometimes write blog posts when I
feel inspired that usually happens on
planes or when I'm super relaxed on
vacation but give me a microphone or a
camera I'll talk all day
proof so if there's a camera or a
microphone I can produce content all day
long so that's why I have a full-time
videographer now I didn't always have a
full-time videographer but I did always
have a $30 microphone that I plug into
my laptop and I start communicating
ideas about business and investing to
the world and I spend a few few hundred
a month to boost that content right that
would be step one at its foundation how
we're going to get this ball rolling and
to be clear the content you're giving
it's a giveaway it's free content what
you're paying for or investing in I
should say is to build an audience right
that's exactly it because there's
there's a a deposit into a relationship
bucket right every interaction that you
have on the Internet or in person is
ultimately a value exchange and your job
at the beginning is to start depositing
checks into that relationship Bucket
from the people who are following you
and if your content is halfway decent
and you're targeting the right people
the people who would benefit the most a
few hundred or a thousand people is
enough to get the ball rolling in terms
of monetization right and I would say
you want to make the deposits in the
relationship account as long as possible
before you ask for a withdrawal right
but for most people at about a thousand
followers that's when we could start to
monetize it yeah and and what's
interesting is that if somebody say well
if I were take that $500 a month and put
it into you know a stock or put into
something else first of all it's then
out of your control uh in the sense that
it's now you're investing in somebody
else's dream not your own yeah but then
secondly the return on this investment
is likely much higher if you build that
audience and get it to that thousand
plus Mark now I first successful
physical products brand was a Sports
Nutrition company called Shear strength
I started I ordered my first line of
product with for
$600 and I sold that for more than $10
million a majority stake for more than
$10 million I still hold a minority
stake which will probably be another 8
figureure payday at some point that's a
pretty good Roi right that's that is
better than Bitcoin
yep that is that is that is better than
any index F right I mean that that only
happens because you are now investing
sweat and and education and intelligence
and time into something that is going to
create an exponential return now there's
a dimension of this the did you have
personally a passion in Fitness Products
absolutely yeah and and how key is it
that you're passionate about whatever it
is that you're looking to promote as
compared to saying I think oh that's a
good idea even though I'm not that uh
emotionally invested in what it is
passion is an
asset it's not a necessity MH passion is
an asset in a field of assets time is an
asset money is an asset connections are
an asset an audience is an asset passion
is an asset okay and all of these things
make results happen faster or they open
up opportunities or they give you the
grit to keep going right so talking
about this with you is energizing for me
it's a passion of mine which means at
the end I'll probably be sad at it's
over right if this since this is my work
day right but at the end I'll be sad
that it's over I'll want to keep going
yeah which means if another interview
showed up I would want to participate in
it right so that's an asset because it
means that I can contribute more it
means that I can do more work because
I've got more energy to do it now for
some people all they have is money but
they have no time or they have no
specific interest or passions so their
Pro their best route is probably to be
an investor great it's your job to analy
the opportunities and deploy your best
asset into however is going to best
serve you for some people all they have
is time so for a while they're just
going to be trading that time for
dollars until they find the thing that
they want to focus on and for some
people it's passion all they want to do
is get up in the morning and golf or
play video games or whatever they're
interested in all of those opportunities
can be monetized I don't have that one
passion that one thing that I want to do
all day and I think part of the the
confusion that people get about passion
is that they think it has to be found
right they think that there's one thing
outside of themselves that they have to
discover and if they don't discover that
one thing then they're never going to be
happy or
successful I am one of those people that
doesn't have that I love baseball my
dream is to own the Cleveland Indians
but after you know 162 Game season I'm
ready for a break now come December I'm
ready for the season to start again but
I I think
that even even I who am passionate about
what I'm doing don't have the one thing
that I could do forever and so I have
more of a feeling that I pursue I have
interests that I cultivate I think
passions and interests are cultivated
not discovered they are we we invest in
them we grow them over time and it
becomes un asset but it is certainly not
the only asset that leads to success so
would you say though that your uh that
capitalism is an overarching passion for
all these things that you're doing that
that's kind of like the the driving
thing that that is is constant fuel for
all these uh your respective activities
I'd say that capitalism is a great word
that represents my Collective interests
and and I studied economics during the
2008 political election M while I was
building my first business and the
economy was tanking so my interest just
happened to be business politics
economics and
talking and so capitalism and leading a
message of capitalism happens to well
represent what I'm doing in the world
and now I guess in your own story as an
example so then you you have a
liquidation event U you you know you
from this business that you created in
the way that you just described how how
how you do it and how you recommend
other people do it and then you pivoted
toward investor um so because now
Investments a part of what you do and I
think again going back to that scenario
of somebody like a dentist or somebody
in that realm that says you know I've
been working for a lot of years I've got
really some Capital now um now and I I
really don't know how to think like an
investor or how to approach you know
making Investments uh do you have
anything to say about that yeah so just
to complete the point I think that if
you don't have a side thing or a
business that is not connected to your
time the first thing you should be
investing in is that right and if you
don't know what that thing is then the
thing you need to be investing in is a
skill set that you can take to clients
or customers and sell in the marketplace
so whether that is running advertising
or it is I know I know somebody who
charges $20,000 to set up a podcast
right because he's one of the best in
the world at submitting your podcast to
iTunes or whatever whatever it is right
so the first thing is do you have a
skill set that you can take to the
marketplace and for a lot of people and
I've seen this work really well for
people they take their job and they go
take a couple side clients and say this
is the result that I get for people
these are the connections that I have
from my 20 years of experience working
at the in the corporate world I can
bring this to your organization and I'm
going to charge you four grand a month
and since now that is your side hustle
and that's your first skin in the game
to have your first business and if
you're building an audience while doing
that getting clients is really easy or
selling product is really easy I know
for example I I have a a friend who's a
medical doctor and this this medical
doctor puts a lot of content out just on
his own personal Facebook page and on
that Facebook page he talks about
inflammation and reducing inflammation
and his opinion on inflammation and why
it's a problem I don't know anything
about this but he talks about it at
length well one day just on a whim he
posts on his Facebook page like I'm
thinking about developing a
supplement that would meet my criteria
for something I think someone should
take or something and he uh he he had
about a hundred people respond to that
and and he started taking deposits for
this first product and delivering it in
in bags like Ziplock bags which looks
super sketchy by the way and and he
pre-sold 100 units at you know he I
think he sold like a an A 3mon or
six-month supply for
$1,000 which funded the buildout of the
entire business which he'll now get
feedback blood work from these patients
and asteris I hope I'm not violating any
medical medical claims by I think you're
okay so far and you have mention any
names here okay so so he'll document
their results share them yep and now
he's Off to the Races in terms of having
a business that he can scale I in the
same way I have uh a student her name is
Sophie she lives in Australia and she
has a a little company called seed and
Sprout and seed and Sprout sells
environmentally friendly kitchen wear
right so so that would be like she has a
reusable containers that are are made of
uh like aluminum and or she has reusable
bags that she sells and she would
developed her first prototype she ran a
Kickstarter posted it on her personal
Facebook page said here's what I'm up to
in the world this is my prototype I want
to I want to take this bigger can you
help her first product was this lunch
box that she sold and she did $225,000
in pre-orders just she did three things
well she posted about it on her personal
Facebook page she went to 10 personal
friends who were passionate about the
topic and said can you please talk about
this on my behalf and she went to a
couple Facebook groups so like
influential type of Facebook groups that
were like 10,000 people right and they
said this is what I'm up to I'm running
a Kickstarter can you help and one of
them said yes and that cumula effect
from all of those different touch points
created $25,000 in pre-orders for a
lunchbox that's enough that's enough to
get the ball rolling so that's that's
the first thing that you should be
investing in if you want to have a side
thing from there right I think you
should be
investing 10% of your take home pay into
long-term wealth building assets that
you never touch what's an example of
that yeah so for me my favorite is
dividend paying stock which is super
unsexy and boring right but I love
dividend paying stock because they have
a double compounding effect a double
compounding effect is some stocks we
call them dividend Aristocrats to give
that give that a Google that is a term
that refers to companies that raise
their dividend every year for at least
25 years a dividend Aristocrat and so if
we look at a company that has raise
their dividend every year consistently
and predictably there's a compounding
effect that happens to that because year
one you're getting a dollar year two
you're getting a120 year three you're
getting a140 A1 6080 $2 forever and ever
I'm in hopefully and so we have a
compounding effect that's happening from
the raise of the dividend but I reinvest
my dividends in to more stock right so
that creates a second compounding effect
so we're buying more stock which is
giving us more dividends which is buying
more stock which is buying more
dividends and so we have a snowball that
starts to roll compounded over 30 years
I'm yet to see any investment on the
stock market outpull those numbers
because you get two compounding effects
compounding against one another so if
someone can show me a better strategy I
would love to see it I've had this
debate with a bunch of financial
planners and my numbers always check out
of dividend long-term dividend paying
stock outperforming just about anything
else in the stock market specifically
now with that 10% going to that the next
thing that I do and again I'm not
recommending any Financial advice but
what I do is I take my profits at the
end of the quarter or the end of the
year and I'm buying cash flowing assets
m cash flowing asset to me is real
estate or real estate syndications or
real estate investment trusts it is I
buy Web businesses my favorite is
websites because a website that profits
$1,000 a month almost passively with a
few hours a month of Maintenance can be
sold for 20 to
$25,000 that's a pretty good deal for
somebody who's just looking for an extra
thousand doll a month and there are some
interesting tax suggestions that some
CPAs will look at and analyze CPA I've
talked to several that disagree with one
another but I've heard some very
interesting proposals on how you could
classify websites as an asset to be more
tax efficient similar to real estate
real estate you get certain write offs
web properties and web businesses have
some similar types of classifications so
it could be very tax efficient income
this would be investing in someone
else's business right we're looking for
a way to passively be involved in
something that is producing cash flow
for us so I like real estate investment
trusts which are publicly traded real
estate companies because they pay really
high dividends I like websites because
the ROI is just absolutely absurd and
they're a sellable asset and I like
investing in businesses so the first
thing is that long-term thing I'm never
going to touch and the second thing
thing is I've now got savings and I'm
going to take that savings I'm going to
try and buy more income with that but
I'm only doing that every quarter or at
the end of every year when I have my
profits left over from my business right
is there certain um Investments that you
look at that maybe you'd say if I were
to look at somebody who was a millennial
versus someone who's you know Gen X or
versus someone who's a baby boomer like
uh depending on the phase of life that
you're in are there certain um buckets
that they that they would fit into
relative to the type of Investments they
should be looking at yeah I I think when
we're looking at investing we we would
prefer that whatever we're investing in
we have some sort of a strategic
advantage in and that would could be
knowledge it could be skill set it could
be people that we know and Millennials
stereotypically are pretty good with
social media so they're going to they're
going to have insight into what emerging
platforms we should pay P attention to
so it might be as practical as there's a
there's a a social media site right now
called twitch which is emerging and
capturing a lot of market share yeah my
son's on it okay there you go so so if
you have a young person who is on The
Cutting Edge of that Trend have them
double down on that because they have a
strategic advantage over someone who is
in an older generation right so it's
going to take you and me a little bit
longer to figure out a brand social
platform than either of our children
right and they're going to have a little
bit of a strategic Advantage there have
them go all in on that whereas somebody
who is older has the benefit of time and
experience we've seen Market Cycles
we've seen ups and downs whereas right
now Millennials have lived through only
boom times in the last 15 years so what
is going to happen when the market has
its next pullback they're probably going
to freak out they're going to
overcorrect oversell they're going to
run for security because they've never
had to see it before but if you're an
older person and you've seen ups and
downs and you've got some in the bank
and you're good that's a good time to
have dry powder to be able to buy up
assets they're going to be incredibly
undervalued when we have the next
pullback so where do you have a
strategic Advantage do you have
relationships that you can bring to a
new investment so for example I
privately only invest in physical
products Brands and the reason for that
is because I've made all of my money in
physical products Brands I have
connections to people in retail I have
connections to influencers who can help
incubate a company I have access to
investors who know that that's my skill
set and they're throwing money at me it
would be really silly for me to try and
pick the next cryptocurrency right
because I have no strategic Advantage
there right now I have invested in
cryptocurrency as we've discussed
partially to keep myself sharp even
though I don't believe in it as a as a
an asset sector M except for one
exception I did invest in one emerging
Ico one
cryptocurrency that was brought to me by
a personal friend of mine who as far as
I know is the most connected person in
the cryptocurrency space and he
specializes in icos and raising money
for ones that he personally backs that
he person invest in that he personally
vets the team and says these are guys
that I believe in now I am not betting
on that cryptocurrency I'm betting on a
relationship right in the same way I
have investors who invest in me because
they're investing in my knowledge and my
strategic Advantage so we've all got
some sort of strategic Advantage either
with people we know with assets we have
with connections or experience or time
and I would say depending on what those
are and that going to largely be
determined by your age and experience
that's where you should start looking at
where you should invest to that point um
when when you're doing Capital raises I
mean when I was out uh raising money for
one of our Ventures uh and I'd get in
front of you the private Equity guys I
asked them all the same question which
was what's the number one thing you look
for in an investment and 100% of 100% of
the time they said the team it's the who
yeah not is this a great idea of course
they have to like the idea but it's who
the person is or who the team is that's
going to bring this into reality so I
think you're making a really really good
point here I like to say that the answer
to almost everything is who yeah I mean
even if we think about experiences that
made us happy mhm usually we're thinking
about who it was with right you can be
in the most beautiful place in the world
and be around people you don't like and
it's not a good experience right whereas
you could be in a small tiny rundown
dorm room and have the best time time
ever because you're with your best
friends right and almost everything
comes down to who success comes down to
who Investments come down to who
happiness love they all come down to who
not what not how those things can be
helpful when can be helpful but who is
ultimately the determining Factor yeah
and you talk about the Arc of
experiencing Cycles Etc I could tell you
when I look back and say okay what
mistakes did I make over the years more
to the point of the who was taking
opportunity over values I I i' look at
you know certain people I want to put
money into or or create a partnership
with and uh and it was such a great
opportunity but there wasn't a values
match between us and even the product is
it a values match in other words are
you're investing in something that's
contradictory to your own values that
also can can lead to some kind of a
problem for you so uh that I think
that's really wise uh investing advice
for people that are out there and I have
almost the exact same experience yeah
yeah it's it's it's not fun and you know
you want to learn after a while so you
don't repeat that one so uh in your
experience what is the timeline
expectation or range of timelines to go
from I'm starting to getting a thousand
people to 90 days you said that so
quickly that there's there's more of a
formula here than than I might
understand it's just experience based on
if you're really in it and going for it
it'll probably take you 30 days to have
a message hit one piece of content that
impacts enough people assuming that you
are then going to ride that and interact
with all of the feedback that comes from
that so if you put out a different
message a different tip a different
strategy a different piece of advice a
different video one of them usually
stands out and creates 80% of that
audience it's then your job to spend the
next 60 days to take that message to as
many people as possible so if I look at
all the videos that I've created I could
point to l less than 10 that have
probably attracted 80% of the business
80% of the eyeballs 80% of the attention
80% of the pr that I've received over
the last 10 years as an entrepreneur I
could also pick out five podcasts five
blog posts five P Facebook posts and
what I'll do is when I see something hit
when I know I've got something if
something gets more shares more likes
more emails or even better people
responding my IDE people to work with
responding to it I then take that post
and I turn it into a video I then turn
that video and we turn it into a blog
post we then turn that blog post and
turn it into a podcast that same message
is going to be distributed to as many
people as possible and what will happen
at that point is then we can take that
message and roll it out to other
podcasts other YouTube channels other
blogs so just today uh this morning one
of my mentors who has uh a huge audience
noticed that I had tipped my cap to him
in one of my videos and I shared on
video a lesson that he had taught me and
he shared that with his audience right
and so someone else saw that and they
clicked the share button and someone saw
that and they click the share button or
one time I had a Facebook
post go semi viral probably got a
hundred shares on Facebook or so and the
people who were sharing it were not the
people who would usually share my
content they were much higher level
individuals so I was connecting with a
really really good market so we turned
that into a video the most viral video
I've ever done we then took that and we
turned it into a podcast released it on
a podcast and what I noticed was that
several other podcasts bigger than mine
who had started tuning in my podcast
based on one of the other pieces of
content I had put out they took the
podcast episode sent me a message said
could we share this on our podcast and
so that one message which was a six
minute message started building holding
my audience doing it one time to many
many people so a lot of a lot of new
entrepreneurs will assume that building
an audience comes down to putting out as
much as possible and that's true until
you find your points that are connecting
then you go scale those with more media
you go scale those with more
relationships you scale that by
Distributing it as much as possible a
thousand people happens as a result in
90 days so if you're somebody that says
well I I uh you know don't know how to
put up all this stuff and to you know
get it implemented I have something to
say but I don't know how to set up a
Blog I'm not sure how to go in market so
if you can't do it yourself what should
you do either figure it out or choose
something that you do understand okay
and if like if you're not willing to
figure it out just don't do it like
seriously just don't do it your message
isn't important enough for you you
should pursue another route you should
go be an investor or or you should start
a business that you do understand so you
have to understand enough to be able to
evaluate those results otherwise you're
just wasting money and you probably
whatever you're thinking about doing
probably isn't that important to you so
now we're talking about content you my
other question was I have content but I
don't know how to program a page I don't
know how to set up optins I don't know
how to you know what what list
management do I use Etc you know these
are a lot of just the fundamentals that
people really need to understand your
advice is go to work and study it and
figure it out and then go once you do or
don't bother now you're saying okay well
I'm trying to figure out content you
said just open up your phone so where
were you going with that particular idea
so once again we're talking about
building audiences right and I think
building audiences is a superpower to
have that first side thing that produces
thousands of dollars a month or your
first million dollars or gives you the
acceleration point to sell a product
right and so that's the context of what
we're talking I don't think it's 100%
necessary that everybody is producing
videos on the internet um I don't even
think it's NE necessary per se to do
this in order to build a business I do
think it's necessary for there to be
some sort of audience in order to make
any product hit now it doesn't have to
be you being the face of it it could be
videos that someone else makes and
you're testing different messages it
could even be just sponsoring other
people's audiences for example if you
didn't want your company or you as a
person to do any content distribution at
all just go pay the people who are doing
it to just their message to talk about
you right and that's called influencer
marketing and the ROI on that is absurd
when done well and very poor when done
poorly but if you have people who are
aligned with your values your mission
and your products it can be very very
lucrative in a way to put a business or
a message or product on the map now if
you are going to be that person that is
Distributing a message it's your job to
experiment with what
messages hit and everybody hates it at
the beginning beginning everybody I'll
tell you a quick story I was um I was on
a plane preparing to give a keynote and
I opened up my laptop to work on the
keynote and my internal noise said man
who wants to listen to me talk about
Business and Entrepreneurship and I was
talking about what we're talking about
right now and I felt like I had nothing
to add to this crowd and all of a sudden
my internal noise started to come inh
and so I said okay well that's
interesting I guess I'll start with that
and so I went on stage and I said I
opened up my laptop to share this with
you and I felt like I had nothing to
share because we are all battling this
internal voice in our head that says
we're not good enough that says we have
nothing to share and I just want you to
know that it's easy for you to sit in
the crowd and look at the people on
stage like they have some sort of
special ability and I don't I'm just a
normal guy who figured out a few habits
that created some success for me and at
no point do I want you to put me on a
pedestal just because I'm a few feet
above you and I'm delivering this
because I feel like I'm one of you and
I've been been sitting in this in this
in the crowd many times idolizing the
people on stage not knowing that they
had their insecurities too so you're
going to feel that come up when I'm
sharing what worked for me and I want
you to know that you're just as good as
me I'm just maybe a year ahead in terms
of my skill set with that let's start
going yeah and it was the most it was
the best part the most well-received
part of the entire keynote is because
all of a sudden it was a feeling that we
gave to them of a freedom and an ease
around permission of feeling uh
inadequate and when I just connected in
that way and shared what was exactly on
my mind that connected with the rest of
the audience so it's not your job to
figure out what to say it's your job to
share what is true for you and what
you've learned over your years of being
in whatever field you're in and seeing
what connects and every time I try to
figure it out here it sucks yeah and
every time I just deeply connect and
share something that's meaningful there
are other people for whom it's
meaningful too yeah well I think there's
a lot of people that have this sort of
secret identity especially people who
are on the platforms right and that's
what you basically took the mask off and
let them see you know what's real but uh
when I'm advising entrepreneurs I
basically tell them you know the the
characterization I use based on the
presentation I do is called you got to
find your Miles Davis in other words
it's what's most purely you inside and
let that out uh and and be vulnerable in
that process because uh you know that
the people who are the right people to
be attracted to you are going to bond
with you for the right reasons right
yeah I think a lot of individuals are
being something that they're not in
order to impress people that they don't
want to hang out with anyway right right
and and I've played that game before and
I I did not find it enjoyable and at
some point you say what do I really want
my life to be like because it does come
down to who who do I really want to
spend my time with with and if I got $10
million or I got $100 million would I
want to spend time with these people and
if the answer is
no we might need to make some
adjustments on our life decisions no
question and you are who you hang out
with you know so who are you around and
that's that's really what you're
aspiring to I remember some years ago i'
had done some programs with deep Chopra
and and one of the things he said to me
that I just thought was was kind of
profound in the realm of what you're
saying is that you said we we buy uh we
buy things we don't want with money we
don't have to impress people we don't
like and it's funny because of how true
it really really was so uh that that's a
uh I love that you got up on a platform
and basically just had no mask on and
just said here's who I am and here's
what we're going to talk about I think
often we're looking for where the
strategy of the formula is that'll
create a certain result and so we
become a reflection of what we think
will produce a certain results and what
I've discovered is
that I've got a
monopoly on one thing and it's being
Ryan Daniel
Moran and I'm the best in the world at
being Ryan Daniel Moran I suck at a lot
of things but I'm really good the best
in the world at being Ryan Daniel Moran
it also happens to be when I'm happiest
yeah and so the more that I can be
myself
and apologetically so the happier I am
and the more I attract people that I
want to work with which allows me to
charge higher prices and which allows me
to be more in my zone of Genius which
allows me to give better results for my
clients and my customers which allows me
to spread a message deeper and wider and
allows me to charge higher speaking fees
and all of a sudden I make more money
the more true I am and the more honest I
am to myself and to other people so if
nothing else I got to Monopoly on being
myself and we all do you're the best in
the world at it so the more you can be
that the more money you end up making so
you were earlier talking about a
blueprint um and saying you know there
was kind of like I think kind of the
stage one of the blueprint is there some
additional Dimensions to that you can
share yeah so when we've got some sort
of a distribution method and that would
be a thousand people following us it
might be the ability to put a product on
amazon.com because now with Amazon's
distribution centers literally anybody
can have a seller account on Amazon you
can Google Amazon FBA account you can
set one up for like 40 bucks and you can
sell products on
amazon.com uh you could have a email
list that is responsive which means you
can sell physical products or webinars
or Consulting if once you have the
distribution mechanism it takes three to
five products selling 30 units a day at
a $30 price point to have about a
million dollar business so that's the
the first stage of it is having the one
product that you release to enough
customers or you say I think I might
have something here and that just
requires you asking your audience would
you want something just like my doctor
friend who said I'm thinking about doing
this I need a 100 people to fund the
whole thing would anybody want it and he
had 100 people say yes and so he didn't
go to a manufacturer and develop this
whole big wonky wonk system he said
would anybody want it all right are you
willing to pay for it and they paid for
it and as a result he was able to fund
the development of that business and
that's win then play rather than spend a
bunch of money and find out if you got
something right and you can get your
mistakes out of the way yeah with people
who wanted to be first in line right so
that's step one that is like stage 1 a
and then when you have something it's
regularly Distributing it to the rest of
the audience you had a hundred people go
through it now can we release it to more
people and when that snowball starts to
roll we can roll out product number two
product number three and on and on until
we have a million dollar business or
more when we have a few products working
it's our job to start going out to other
audiences and that's when people know
you enough for you to be able to have
some sort of authority to get on other
people's podcasts for you to be
communicating to other blogs and on
other YouTube channels that's when
influencers start to pick you up up it's
when you bring on other team members who
have other skill sets and that's when
you can really start to scale something
Beyond a million if that's what you want
to do really interesting for me the way
that you've organized this in your
thinking in presentation is demystifying
a lot of it and also putting it into
bite-sized shoes right so that it's like
this is the chunk you get to this level
then this is the next one and and you're
also I think mitigating risk because
you're not spending a ton of time and
money until there's certain Milestones
that are checked off so so it looks like
Far Side Simplicity and it seems simple
now but there had to be a complexity Arc
and a lot of learning to get you there
I'm assuming well what I I think this
does is it gives people permission to
get started yeah because it removes all
of the heaviness and the risk around
trying to eat the whole elephant in one
bite right and if we realize that we can
test things before we get too involved
that gives us permission to say all
right I'll experiment and we realize
that the downside when we're just
playing for a while is very low whereas
most people and I I'd say 80% of my work
with entrepreneurs is getting them to
stop overthinking it right and that is
that they're here they want to go here
and they say how do I how do I get here
right and what I tell them is we got we
got we got to get to the first step like
that that's what we have this the only
thing we need we cannot get here without
getting here first and so what all I
need to do is get them to take that
first step and then the second step and
the third third step whereas most people
think about the marathon the whole time
and we can run a marathon sure but we
can't run a marathon without taking the
first step and so when we distill down
what it would take to get some skin in
the game all of a sudden it doesn't seem
so scary any other considerations uh for
people who are looking to create side
hustle you know they they basically say
uh I've got a decent career I want to
create more um I'm willing to you know
give time money energy to be able to
create something more any other cases
about people who' have done this that
you think might be valuable or other
ideas beyond what you've already stated
that might well one one thing that I'll
say is I would not recommend getting
into anything unless you are willing to
commit to it for a year I take a rule
that I don't evaluate any result until
I've been into something for a year and
sometimes it's simply putting out enough
videos knowing I want to see what will
hit but I won't know for a year MH and
and I might test doing 30 videos over 30
days and decide I don't enjoy it right
but I still won't evaluate the result
until I've had a year to see if one of
them caught on and I have had that
happen where a video was dud and then
six months later someone picked it up
and it became a viral sensation I have
had that happen and and we won't know
that for a year I've had that happen in
with podcast that had happened with
products where you were too early on a
product and then a year later all these
customers flooded in right so I'm not
saying you have to work at something for
a year but we have to wait at least a
year to be able to evaluate any result
that's possible at at at all so if
you're not willing to wait a year for
the result you probably don't want to be
in that thing and that allows us to say
no to a lot of things that we probably
won't enjoy doing and so if you're if
you're willing to wait a year then we
can backtrack okay what are we going to
enjoy doing for the next year or how can
we orchestrate our lives so that we're
in a position to enjoy it for the next
year while we evaluate the result well
there's a ton of wisdom in that because
I think that's another thing when you're
coming to this new uh what is what
expectation should I have you know so
many of the things that are sold out
there to teach you how to do this it's
like you know lack of a better phrase
you know get rich quick or you know
overnight results Etc testimonials but
really there has to be some sort of a
timeline and and one of the things talk
about you know a lot of experience uh
perseverance used to be one of my core
values so on the other side of that
equation now I say perseverance is a
virtue until it isn't you know I have
sunk millions of dollars into Ventures
over a period of protracted time pushing
a rock up the hill because I don't give
up etc etc etc I'm like after I've done
that a couple of times I'm realizing how
do now my now my value is how do I fail
fast how do I find out as compared to
torture myself for a long period of time
yes so on the one side you're saying you
can't really measure results for a year
which I think is really good wisdom and
then the other side at what point do you
find out maybe you know this is not the
the right message or the right message
to Market match when you stop enjoying
it I have I have a a mentor named Travis
who reminds me to ask myself the
question what would I be
doing even if I was failing my ass
off I heard I heard the story once of uh
Jerry Seinfeld who is either a
billionaire or close to being a
billionaire a comedian that's a
billionaire that that doesn't happen
right he says that when he first started
if he could just pay for dinner based on
what he made from Comedy that was like
amazing to him and it made me think
what's that thing that I'd be stoked if
I just got enough to pay for dinner
right and I again I don't have that
thing I don't have that passion I'm more
of a feeling I pursue I I I have I have
a a a way of life that I like to pursue
I have I I pursue excitement so how do I
get paid to live in that place right and
so what that requires me to do is
anything that doesn't move me closer to
that I say no to and I and I went to my
team recently and I said all right the
one thing in our business if it's built
around me if it requires me then I've
got to be pursuing excitement so from
now forward the primary question if
we're going to pursue anything new is
does this make me excited or does this
not make me excited and if it does we'll
say yes to it and if it if we go well
will'll make a lot of money and money's
exciting no because I know I'm going to
burn out on that it doesn't mean it's
not a good Financial move in the short
run it just means that I'm going to end
up burning out which means I'm probably
not going to create what I want to
create to get the result that I want
evaluating a year back MH there's two
things that I learned early in life from
my Uncle Tom that he shared with me that
became very good business and investing
advice the first was spend your money on
things that people can't take away from
you mhm at the time I was learning
guitar and he said they can take your
guitar but they can't turn your they
can't take away your knowledge of how to
play guitar right and experiences
connections relationships these are all
things that no one can take away from
you and when you're starting as an
entrepreneur when you're starting a new
business when you're going a new
Direction in life spend your time and
your money on things people can't take
away from you great we have to have some
sort of a skill set we have to have some
sort of value that we're creating in the
world MH so when you're a new
entrepreneur when you're when you're
when you're new to the game when you're
pursuing a new life the first thing is
to invest in things that people can't
take away from you that's skill sets
it's education it's relationships and
those are the thing that are going to
have the highest Roi in your business
when you were first starting out and
then the other thing that Uncle Tom
taught me was as an investor the thing
that I look for and he was looking for
and passed on to me was 1% per month mhm
that's our target range for profitable
investment we're not looking for home
runs we're looking for lots and lots of
singles and doubles 1% per month if
that's a $100,000 investment it means I
want to be making at least $1,000 a
month from that
$100,000 and if I can't get that at some
point in the future I'm going to wait
for the right opportunity where I will
be able to get that if what I'm looking
for is cash flow then 1% per month is my
Target that's where I evaluate my deals
so all great wisdom uh and uh I think
very uh actionable you know as far as
what you're communicating here it's not
just abstract it's really actionable
stuff uh so I really appreciate you
sharing this with me any final thoughts
in these Realms before we tie up
ultimately we don't get rich trading our
our hours for dollars we get rich
producing value in the marketplace it's
why capitalism is the most beautiful
system in the world it's the only system
through which we're actually compensated
for the value that we bring and I'm so
saddened by the mindset of waiting for
somebody else to tell us what're worth
in the form of minimum
wage um or hoping that somebody else
does something in order to help us get
ahead right if you want to get ahead you
bring new value to the marketplace you
learn new skills you develop new
relationships and you bring those to the
company that you work in or customers
and clients who are willing to pay you
more than what you're getting at your
job it is always about what other people
are willing to pay and something that
has really helped me recently is
shifting from thinking about what can I
get out of this to how can I create and
how can I give and not only how can I
give but who can I give to because
sometimes the problem and the thing
that's holding us back is not you and
it's not your problem product it's just
the person that you're marketing it to
so an idea or a service the same one can
be worthless to one person and worth
$110,000 a month to somebody else same
person so sometimes just changing the
person that you are speaking to is
enough to go from failure to millionaire
just because of who values it value is
subjective value is person to person and
when we're not getting the results that
we want it just means that we need to
adjust our positioning in the
marketplace either what we're providing
or who we're providing it to and these
things are always changeable they're
always hackable none of it is stagnant
it's constantly changing it forces us to
be on our Edge our be on our best to be
always moving forward and growing and so
this free society that we all want
literally forces us to be better every
day great step thanks for being such a
great champion of capitalism and my
pleasure and sharing all this passion
with this audience uh I I really believe
you delivered a lot of value today so
thank you so much thanks for having me
to see the next episode in the money
revealed series check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there let me just declare my bias right
up front I am a capitalist I believe in
capitalism I think capitalism is the
collectively the greatest thing the
Humanity's ever created it has
completely changed the world